oh my god connor joey what are those
amazing mugs you've got there sir i
couldn't hear you over staring at my
beautiful mug the trash taste with a lid
oh my god oh my god is that the trash
taste mug that you can get from
trashtastemugs.com and there's only two
weeks left as well only two weeks left
well like you better snatch my bug now
there's only two weeks left
tastemugs.com comes with a lid 29.99
plus shipping two weeks left and once
the two weeks are gone they're gone
forever so you better go to it right now
and snag it if you haven't yet oh my god
i wish i just knew about
trashtastemugs.com to get these mugs
right now i'm just so grateful that i
have a perfectly sized mug for any
beverage of my wanting and it's got a
lid so you can keep cold things cold and
warm things warm
joey just explained science
back to the episode
[ __ ] love that meme i'm literally
coming
back
here we go
welcome to this episode of trash taste
with me your host connor and the boys
joey and gant that's us that's us
nice of you to be hosting uh the manga
episode right i was gonna get into that
gone okay we're all gentlemen here we're
all we're all uh connoisseurs of the
fine arts we'll read words
you know the trash taste law right you
you know our character development and
you know you know the best reader of all
time is obviously connor exactly
i am reading
that's it librarians wish they could
have connor's brain right now they they
wish they could access this fountain of
knowledge
and we thought obviously the best host
for the manga centric episode which we
are going to be doing today we don't
choose host scan
it's a rotation yeah and it just the
stars aligned they were sending us a
message just like it's connor's turn
caught a mustache who's the mongoose
episode yeah so that's what we're doing
today like you've hosted the dojinchi
episode as well i just realized my
complete chance and now you've also
hosted the manga episode right gonna say
i read yeah
i'm somewhat of a reader myself
anyway yeah as we've said this is the
manga episode of trash taste where we're
gonna be discussing our favorite mangas
on our favorite preferred method which
is gonna be the three by three which you
see on there we've talked about manga in
the past in a lot of different episodes
but uh i don't think we've actually
established like what our all-time
favorite manga is or like our manga
tastes cool yeah it's it's really weird
because when we were thinking about what
if what haven't we like specifically
talked about on theme in an episode and
i was like wait a minute we've never
talked about manga and for some reason i
just assumed that we already had yeah
because it feels like we have right yeah
exactly but like it just i was like well
we did the anime once obviously we did
the mongols right right
and of course i'm a bit uh
thinking i was thinking about the fact
that
i wonder because the movie one that we
did recently uh is probably gonna have a
lot more variation i feel like this must
be some more overlap this time right
yeah i'm i really don't know like
there's one or two i'm like i'm pretty
sure if it's not on your list you would
put it on your list anyway there's at
least one i know that i probably i mean
yeah you're kind of limited in your i
mean you're so expensive i mean i i know
i've probably got at least one that's
the same as you i think i might have one
that's the same as joey as well here's
what i realized uh when i recently read
uh records of ragnarok yeah is that i've
only read really long running manga yeah
i've not i don't think i've read a
single manga that had like less than 150
chapters
i would actually agree with you on that
i've it's okay so i realized when
picking my three by three is that there
isn't that much choice or there isn't as
much choice as there is in the anime
world right of like manga that really
left a deep impression on me and that's
because like manga you know if if you
watch a season of anime it actually
takes less time to consume it than
reading a really long running manga
series because if it's like a like a one
shot or like a one volume kind of thing
it probably was not going to leave that
deep of an effect on me i don't know man
i've read a lot of one shots that were
like man this is
dead ass better than some like yeah
donald trump one shot
that was good that left an impression on
me i didn't expect to see manga donald
trump but
surely that given uh
i didn't realize how much i missed death
note until i read that one shot and i
was like damn we kind of need a sequel
to death he was just playing with us
that's the worst part is that it was
like it was like uh you know like the
pro coming back and just styling on
everyone and then being like see you by
the way yeah i mean like just being like
i could come back yeah i could kill it
it's like that villain wrestler who just
comes in clotheslines and then
builds all your furniture leaves yes
yeah but then i also realized making
this 3x3 is that i really haven't read
as much manga as i have watched anime i
mean i i'm i'm unfortunately not the
manga man that's probably joey right i
think i think in your head you feel like
manga is easier maybe maybe because
you're you can speak you can read
japanese fluently maybe
it is because you can just pick them up
yeah you should go to the store pay two
bucks get the manga and you're good to
go i mean as someone called the anime
man i obviously read a lot more monkeys
yeah
you know as we all know about it
and i i do think that if that was the
case i think i would probably read more
yeah but i think because the fact that
i'm not i do enjoy reading digitally i
like the ease of it but i do find that
it's a little more
i don't know it feels harder to get into
yeah i don't know why i mean digitally
yeah when i'm reading it i like it yeah
yeah but it's getting into it where i'm
like i don't know because when you when
you see it in the store you can pick it
up you can flick it through you're like
oh okay there's no better feeling than
like a physical right right right that's
when you really get into it right manga
because unlike normal books you have to
actually just read it
it pops right out you can see oh okay oh
and it feels a bit more intimate i guess
and i i guess like most the manga that i
put on my three by three i actually read
i've read on paper
and uh i feel like i don't know if
that's a complete coincidence some of
them some manga i know are really good
and i purposely will not read it unless
it's physical copies yeah um other manga
i kind of like i maybe read online and
if it's like good then i try to go out
my way to buy physical copies
yeah but i mean i like i'm saying i
think that for me at least a little bit
anime is slightly easier to consume it
really depends i don't really understand
how i consume manga
i don't really get it i think i like it
i understand but i don't think i
i get it it depends on the series for me
definitely like there are somewhere just
like i really [ __ ] struggled to like
get into the manga but for some reason
it's really easy to watch the anime vice
versa yeah also another thing when i was
picking my three by three is like i
really did i tried not to pick
titles that already had like a big anime
adaptation or had or something that i
watched the anime and i feel like it
doesn't make a change
you're trying to be like like i don't
watch the meme i don't read the means no
because it's trying to be the artist
okay for example like i don't think
there's any point me putting one piece
on on my on my three by three so it is
the
because the manga is the one with
everyone asking me why when i started it
yeah yeah because like the manga is
amazing but i feel like with that you
could easily you could either read the
manga or watch the anime and you could
either have like a good experience on
each and everybody i don't think there's
a single person watching trash taste
that doesn't know what one piece yeah
and i'm just like and i'm just like do i
really need to tell my trash taste
viewers that i am a one piece fan
do you really need to know that i
i was my japanese class this morning and
uh it was like they made me listen to
like japanese people speak and tell them
what they were saying and i got totally
thrown off in one audio clip because
there was a woman talking about her
dress but it's one of the other ones
yeah one pizza and i was like
oh she likes red one one
piece
i was like so thought i couldn't listen
to the rest of it like yeah should you
say one piece like the anime that you
know we should have like the ptsd
yeah i was like one piece
i can't escape it
when i was first getting into one piece
i really wanted to buy the manga volumes
obviously
yeah i typed in one piece on ebay and
i'm just like don't give me a [ __ ]
dress i want the manga give me the manga
and i scroll down it's just like dress
dress dress dress dress it's like god
damn it
all right gentlemen there it's time
okay all right trash talk box [ __ ]
inside it all all right
man we've got some real mileage out of
this
dollar
thanks navi
you're the real mvp here
he's my son
4k hearing
4k
who's going first all right first up let
me get the traction all right yeah first
up
is conor spelled incorrectly connor
who did this
it's an oh
i'm kidding yeah i'm first uh i think
i've actually only read coincidentally
like nine
i can
can we make a guess
can we make a guess before uh before you
show them uh do you want to confirm if
you're right or wrong you can just okay
okay well obviously jojo part seven yeah
berserk yep
claymore
uh i shield 21. i shield
gantz that's five
um
reckless ragnarok no that wouldn't be on
there
is this something what's what's like
something else what's the cockroach one
again oh terrifying oh terrifying i
didn't put that on oh oh damn
we'll talk about that yeah we'll talk
about that as well um what else has he
read um saga yeah villain saga that's
seven i can't think of any more that
he's ready maybe maybe did you read
death now to watch it i think he watched
it he watched it you know what all right
we got we've got you're gonna kick
yourself when you missed you missed one
that you're gonna be like of course i
know there's one that's like very
obviously we missed all right ashley
pull it up pull it up put it up on the
screen
oh one punch man dude oh one punch man
of course oh black baller oh and uh
so uh let's go do a bit of self promo
real real quick
love i love this manga so much that i
made an audio book of it you can go buy
it by the way on bookwalker uh you want
my princess full audiobook edition is it
not condone of this software yeah i
wasn't allowed to do this but i'm doing
it anyways just by the way
it's actually okay
i don't think that's where terraformers
would go yeah okay okay we'll get into
town i'll quickly actually i will
lightly touch on this it's actually an
act genuinely a really good br story
okay yeah you want to get into bl uh
it's it's good man it's about a guy
who's like yeah dude i i like this guy
but i don't i don't know this isn't
normal right
but then but then yeah he really likes
the guys
that's literally every alley yeah
no a lot of them are really rapey oh
yeah a lot of them are like oh you don't
like me well let me make you come and
that'll change your mind and it's like
yeah cyberpunk music it's like hold on
what
it's like
no no don't say it no it's not weird
it's not weird if you make it sharper
yeah but it's actually a really
wholesome manga
and yeah if you want to listen to an
audiobook form you can uh officially
like anyway you want to go through the
list in case there are some things in
some cases we didn't mention them
already yep so uh you got most of them
right claymore one punch man berserk
jojo black butler gantz vinland saga and
i show 21. i wasn't expecting black
butler there for some reason actually
okay i thought you were more of a fan of
the anime i didn't realize you wrote the
manga of that yeah i've read what
chapter i read up to i've read a good
chunk of black below i haven't caught up
because i know that a bunch of [ __ ]
happened and there's a lot of big plot
twists that i know about but i haven't
read yet right uh but i've read most of
black butler and it's so so much better
in manga format than anime because the
first yeah really the first okay the
first season is basically like kind of
like a i don't know episodical slice of
life kind of thing that doesn't really
progress the story that much yeah and
the second season is just non-canonical
right of black butler
saw that sorry
i
you know people kind of want to be like
oh he's the black butler guy but yeah i
don't like it i don't want to talk about
it now um but yeah the third season of
black butler the anime is based on like
the manga and it's amazing like it's
like a really morbid part it's really
dark and you kind of realize how good it
can be yeah um but yeah the manga is a
really really good good read and i'd
recommend it if you kind of like the
idea of black butler but don't want to
go through with the anime yeah and i
wouldn't have read it if it wasn't for
my youtube videos yeah because like i've
heard the second season of black butler
is that different from the manga
yeah completely
um but like genuinely give the manga a
shot it's it's pretty good so what's
like different about the manga than the
anime that would you would recommend the
manga over it
well it's like way more serious way more
like it doesn't like [ __ ] around and it
doesn't really feel like because the
anime very much feels like it's kind of
just yowie bait at times yeah yeah it's
definitely generally pertained to its
audience yeah and it's very and the
first season again it's very casual it
doesn't really
it it does it does cover a lot of the
same things but it does it in a way that
i've just i think oh okay i watched
season one of the anime and i thought it
was like it's fun it's fun but the the
manga does it so much better it does so
much more justice and i feel today's
like art style is a lot just like more
gritty and like kind of different it's
so good well she gets better as well and
it's so good and the third seed of black
bat like covers like a circus arc yeah
and it's so good and the anime does it
justice
of circles
is like the anime finish now or or is
the manga finish sorry i think the man
is still going the manga is still
ongoing oh it's still going it's still
going okay it's quite long running and
um i don't know how many volumes around
i think we're over like 13 at this point
i think it's way more quite a lot i
think it's like over 20 now is it really
over 25. i think i've already read up to
like
10
all right but i really enjoyed it i
wanted i don't know why i stopped i'd
probably go and read it because you know
when you catch up to a certain point
you're like i'm done yeah
for me like my manga reading habits is
that i just love binge reading martial
yeah so much i can't once
30 now volume 30 of black butler i know
i've read over
half i think right but i don't know how
long ago that was because i think what
was happening is that i got really burnt
out on it because i read so much of it
in like your space and your entire
career was yes
yeah then that happened then i got which
but i think this is probably going to
remind me to get back into it
because with one punch when i did that
as well which we'll talk about later
yeah but genuinely i think even though
if you've seen the show i would give it
a shot yeah i've definitely i i did
remember giving the black butler manga a
go like after i finished watching season
one yeah because i just at that point
season two had already finished airing
and i just heard yeah don't watch season
two yeah so i was like all right time
for the manga then and i just never got
to it yeah and there's some it's
really really dark at times like you
forget like the main premise is that in
black butler he hits a demon and then
he's made a contract with him yeah yeah
to have his life at the end yeah yeah
and like they kind of play off it a lot
in the anime and make it seem like oh
it's kind of hot huh it's kind of
okay you know but uh yeah in the manga
they constantly remind you sometimes
like oh [ __ ] he just like murders people
like yeah they're straight up and
they're not afraid of like showing like
really morbid stuff yeah some really
good plot twists you know like i won't
spoil some of them but there's some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens in
that right and it's really worth giving
it a shot even though all the stereo not
stereotypes what the all the uh what's
the word
facade i guess facade or the
preconceptions that a lot of the western
anime fans have i think in japan it's
pretty [ __ ] popular i think oh yes
but it's popular but it definitely does
have like a strong female audience yeah
i mean sebastian is iconic yeah i mean
being the sexy man
yeah yeah i mean he was like the sexy
man of anime for like the early two the
early to mid-2000s i still argue if you
make a list of top five sexiest anime
characters sebastian's on like yeah he
is just sexy he just has that like she
has that like cult folks hit the pubs
[Music]
it's black butler in it like he's just
he's just an icon of his time for like
anime and manga at the time like for
like there's there's a few like i'd say
characters in like anime that just
personified a certain character trait
like do you think of yandere for our
generation he's [ __ ] you know right
right you know what i mean you think
sexy man it's sebastian from black
butler yeah don't think anyone's
replaced him yet yeah i know i mean the
one that got close was maybe like yuri
from uranus oh yeah but even then even
then
yeah yeah i don't think he's just i
don't think he's just charming
is just a staple of like it's like the
sexy butler yeah of and but also just
very swat very charismatic yeah like
it's very entertaining and i feel like
sebastian does carry it a lot of the
time because he's just so fun and even
though he is like obedient he's just he
makes it so entertaining yeah and and
you know again and even my videos i
didn't didn't even remotely do him
justice he's such he's so witty and so
clever in the anime and the manga sorry
it's it's so he's so fun to watch
and the uh you know the third season of
the anime is good and the uh book of
murder i think it's called is that
correct book of murder is pretty fun
it's like kind of like a mini whodunit
right all right within like in like two
hours it's pretty fun that's cool yeah
and it's uh obviously
sebastian solves everything and does it
magically which is always fun because
because it's like what if shakamoto
became a butler later on in life
that that is
i feel like sebastian and sakamoto are
just like they're lyrics
you know what i mean they're literally
the same person
sakamoto is just sebastian in school
yeah
because they literally have the same
kind of like it's
maybe maybe sakamoto is a little more uh
tongue-in-cheek yeah but sebastian very
much has the same kind of uh visual
humor a lot of the time and does like a
lot of
you know he's the joke is often that he
is just so insanely competent at
everything he's just so op he is
literally opie as [ __ ] but it's amazing
like it's so good i just love it it's so
and it's i feel like there's
this not a manga that that has the same
feeling as black butler i don't think
there's a single manga that feels like
it or anime show that has the same kind
of vibe yeah yeah yeah i feel it
definitely like created a staple for
that
genre like there's probably a lot of
manga that's imitating black butler 100
percent
yeah because there's not many manga out
there that do like
deal with like pretty intense themes
they have like all these like thriller
aspects they also have the the you know
the what parts that appeal to the fuji
is quite a lot yeah right so it kind of
mixes a lot of genres together and i
think even jana tobaso herself said that
she didn't even know what genre she'd
put it in
because it's so it touches on so many
genres throughout the manga yeah that's
why i think it's super unique and worth
worth reading
okay did you watch the anime or read the
manga first anime first okay i should i
should have expected that actually yeah
so anime i got into so i watched the
anime yeah and you know i thought
wow i just watched it and i thought it
was kind of man that's kind of boring
i thought it was okay you know i thought
season two was god awful yeah and at
this time book of six hadn't came out
yet and uh basically i i did that and
then someone was like oh you should uh
you should just do like character
impressions for my youtube channel yeah
well okay i did a few and then sebastian
just happened to be the one that i tried
first and i thought it sounded nothing
like him
like a british butler guy right oh my
god it's him but looking back i'm like
it doesn't even sound like j michael
taylor
but you know i'm sure he was offended
that people were i'd be offended
uh and then i did that and then i got
you know i got surrounded by people who
loved it and you kept like telling me
read it read it yeah i was like
reluctant i was like no so wait what
what was the first manga you ever read
first is it on the three by three
that you like distinctly remember it
might have been black but no it must
have been black butler yeah blackballer
it was black butler and i didn't read
any for like two years right
he just thought manga equals blackboard
because
the reason why i actually got into i
remember this next i did a manga dub of
uh part of the uh the uh a couple of the
boat arcs called the campaign companion
just the border the white sock the book
of atlantic is it
book of atlantic i think we called it
because they made a movie about it i
haven't watched the movie um i did a
comic dub of a portion of that and so uh
yeah i just ended up reading it because
i was like oh this song looks cool and i
had it out of context and i was like oh
okay uh well this is cool i'm gonna go
read the rest and i started reading it
and i read past that point and then i
stopped right but everything before i
enjoyed but i'm probably gonna go finish
it yeah because what i want to know is
that i'm looking at most of these and
i'd say
a lot of these have come from
recommendations literally from us
telling you like go out and read it i
know exactly which one's got recommended
i know which ones i recommended
so
so let's do it in the order of i watched
that i read them yeah yeah yeah yeah go
go for it okay so next up was one punch
man okay yeah so what what inspired you
to read one punch man i guess the
animator yeah season one was too good
how can you you can't [ __ ] block me like
that right like season one was so good
yeah yeah and uh
i saw the manga and i was like oh a lot
of the times when i'd see the manga and
i when i wanted to go further like past
the anime we start reading the mark and
everything ah it's not the same yeah
but one punch was the one where i was
like holy [ __ ] this is insane yeah like
this this artwork is just
insane yeah i noticed you have two
murata yusuke manga yeah i love his art
man
yeah and he's so good at visually
conveying like action action and also
just kind of like metaphors i've seen
godly yeah let's talk about i swear like
because i think especially in sports
anime yeah sports anime a lot of times
live and die by the metaphor yeah right
right because how how because concepts
need to be explained yeah yeah because
like how can you convey a certain move
or a certain like aspect of a sport that
people who are do not understand a sport
can easily understand you go for
metaphors and by far the manga that does
the best of visual metaphors is i sure
21. you know [ __ ] your high q and your
[ __ ] christmas
this is why i would want him to do a
chat anime you would explain the concept
of chess through metaphors
yeah yeah like this is a pin and he'd
figure out some weird [ __ ] way of
showing it i would love that but yeah
sadly it's not popular in japan
big rip but yeah one punch man i i just
like dude this one was still to this day
one of my favorite mangas out of all of
these i still think that one punch man
is
maybe one of my favorites right it's so
hard it's that's the difficult one
because you have jojo because jojo is
there as well and i think jojo might be
my favorite obviously um
but ah i think jojo is my fa is it like
because i have a difference between my
favorite and the one i enjoyed the most
yeah right and i think i enjoyed one
punch man the most because it was just
pure fun yeah yeah but jojo is my
favorite because there's so much about
jojo that i love oh yeah and i love the
style of jojo i love all of that and i
feel like giorgio is so much more than
just the margaret it's experience
it's a culture you know you don't just
read jojo you believe it you live it you
experience it you become jojo there's
just something about jojo which we'll
talk about later but yeah just there's
something about it um but one punch man
man like i finished season one
and i was like okay i'm gonna check it
out i'ma see what happens after yeah
because it ends because i mean after you
watch the boros fight uh which you know
if you haven't if you don't know what
one punch man is i'm gonna explain to
you it's a guy who beats everyone in one
punch that's literally it and he's a man
and at the end of the season one of the
anime he has this amazing fight that is
so visually stunning yeah and just
amazing and it's so hype but it's
probably one of the coolest animated
fights in anime yeah um
and i was like okay i have to know where
this can go because everyone's saying
the story is amazing onwards so i
started reading it and i was like oh
okay this is pretty cool the next arc
starts and i'm like okay this is really
interesting right because we start the
uh what's known as the monster arc yeah
and the garo arc
yeah and they introduce gara which is
like the one of the main characters
going forward in the in the anime and
manga and season two covers uh i'd
probably say the beginning just barely
the beginning of one of the the it's a
long rock yeah it's very long it's still
ongoing on the on the manga um yeah i
started reading it and i was like god
damn this man's drawings are just
another level yeah yeah actually insane
it's it's insane because i remember
reading one punch man before the anime
came out because everyone was hyping it
up so i was like it was the one show
when i'm just like let me let me just
see let me just read like a chapter or
two just to see
what can i what i can expect so i tried
reading a chapter or two and then i read
everything that was out you can't then
you can't pick that up and not read
everything that's impossible and then i
remember reading and being like there's
no way the anime is gonna live up to
this fight
i was just like there's no [ __ ] way
but like not not because the r is like i
think some of the best art that's
available i mean there's
when you turn the there's a panel right
where saitama punches so hard yeah the
clouds split yeah yeah and in this panel
you like the detail on the earth yeah
and the clouds is insane no there's some
panels that are literally just animated
keyframes yeah where you read it and
it's it's it's just like it's just like
an anime because it's just basically
keyframes right so like i was very very
impressed at you know the team at mad
house for be being able to put their own
spin on his amazing [ __ ] art yeah
like living up to this amazing art but
even without that one punch man is some
of the best battle shown in like 100
arts yeah that you can find in all of
anime and manga yeah and i think that
we're i'm very glad that one punch man
season one was animated the way there
was because i think anime season one
is more of a comedy yeah and then season
two onwards is an action i feel like the
comedy very much takes a seat after the
first arc well yeah because i mean you
can only do so much with that single
concept right yeah but but like the way
that they made it work every time was so
genius and funny like one punch man
season one is one of the funniest shows
in anime yeah and in the manga i feel
that although the art is much better i
feel like the comedy doesn't hit as hard
because the comedic timing is super
important for jokes and i feel like you
can't have as good comedic timing when
you're reading something as when you're
experiencing it the joke i think i think
it's just like a different experience or
difference it's a difference but a joke
a joke read aloud will always be funnier
than a joke you've read
like that's just oh
i don't know i disagree
i thought that too until i read like
stuff like guinta
yeah but i bet the gintama animes
delivers the lines funnier
i don't know it's hard to say like
sometimes it does yes but then there are
some chapters that i i think gintama is
the only manga that's genuinely made me
laugh out loud reading it yeah and
that's like a very powerful thing to say
right because like
again it's like as you said a joke is
much funnier said out loud yeah but it's
like timing timing you know everything
playing into the joke yeah there's so
many aspects that can help elevate the
joke i think that i think that comes
down to at least with manga how good you
are at like framing yeah right and i
think munata yusuke is so [ __ ] good
at framing yeah like a concept yeah that
he can just somehow do that with comedy
as well he already proved it with actual
21's like action scenes yeah and he this
man can also do comedy as well i'm like
what can this man not do yeah i've read
the original one webcomic oh yeah yeah
how was that
yeah it's it's a it's a lot harder to go
to
um
but also i know so explain one can't
draw that's why so the original the
original yeah the original uh one punch
man is a webcomic i'm sure you guys know
this it's a webcomic and then um
picked it up and was like hey let me
draw good for you like real good yeah
and and then published in shonen not
jump it used to be jump right jump plus
jump plus now right it's once a month
which is painful because i think uh juan
did weekly is it i believe the webcomic
is over now right is it um kind of like
it's not over it's just on hiatus oh
okay cause i've read up to everything
that's out and it's just kind of in the
middle of an arc right now
yeah but like the manga
right now is adapting
the it's so it's in the monster arc
stuff yeah it's it's still in the
monster arc so it's taken the webcomic
it's kind of like a like a basis and
just really expanding on that yeah i've
noticed because that they've
in the the difference between the hmong
and the webcomic is that they've
put aspects of the story that happened
they've moved them around yeah the manga
into like better timings yeah yeah like
there's some characters that got their
backstory um
in the webcomic at a certain time that
they were shifted to them when they were
having a fight yeah they got the
flashback and their backstory uh like
there's a superhero called super black
alloy
who is a man that is super muscular yeah
that's his thing and he gets his
flashback at a different time but in the
actual uh the redone manga he gets it
during one of his fights with garu right
um which i noticed was oh okay that's
interesting i didn't i didn't know they
were mixing things around yeah um but
yeah the manga is
oh my god just take one look at some of
these panels and you'll be you'll be
yeah you'll be reading it
yeah it's definitely one of the best
action manga i've ever read if not the
best honestly uh yeah it's hard i can't
think of anything that in terms of pure
action and fights that comes close in
mind yeah i mean i haven't read many so
i can't say but i mean i still think
it's one of the best it's definitely one
of the best yeah this episode is
sponsored by expressvpn
um
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like taking a call on the train or
bus on speaker for everyone to hear and
who wants to do that no one did you know
that your internet service provider can
see every single website you visit
you're joking no i'm not joking i might
as well just strip in front of them but
did you know there is a way that you can
stop it using expressvpn goddammit they
won't even see a website that you go to
this west vpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so people can't peep on your
online activity it's really easy to use
just fire up the app and click one
button and you're connected to the
internet in a different country plus is
rated number one by cnet wired the verge
works on your phones laptops even
routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi can be protected honestly i use it
all the time it's super easy it works on
phone laptop like you said you literally
just started out press one button and
it's like done in seconds i mean you've
been using it to watch the uh olympics
right yeah right now it's super good
it just works it just works it just
works i have no complaints yeah keep
your online activity today by visiting
expressvpn.com
trash taste that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n dot com slash trash
taste and you can get an extra three
months for free
trash taste links in expressvpn.com
description back to the shop i i really
like uh
i really as you said terraformers
terraforms is great actually that was a
great moment yeah but like
the story is kind of mad at times yeah
but the action is spot on it's so cool
i've spoken about terraforms before but
terraformers is just uh it's a manga
which is one of my favorites and i've it
has like a ridiculous amount of chapters
i think like 400 something i think it
has
it's like 30 it's almost 30 volumes i
think yeah and it's like i think they
just started a new arc yeah when i
stopped reading it and it felt like it
was going to be the last and biggest arc
and i was like [ __ ] me i think it's
already finished has it finished i think
has it i don't know no way because i
only read up to him around like
volume like 11 or 12. so the concept of
terraformers uh which i
dude i was so [ __ ] sold on this
concept because i was like that's
[ __ ] bad yes it's very cool so
they're they they sent a mission to
explore uh the moon
and when they got there there was
cockroaches that could just they were
just ripped like giggity chat like
giga chances
someone had shot their fridge into the
moon and they had cockroach on there
yeah
sorry
it's like giga chad cockroach i know we
spoke about terraforms before on like
the third episode or something yeah it's
been a while yeah so there's uh there's
cockroaches on the moon and turns out
they're not just any normal cockroaches
they're giga chad cockroaches that are
like super human beings super smart but
have the senses of cockroaches yeah so
this whole team dies that goes there and
you see this right away so it's not a
spoiler um so that then earth goes and
they're like we must do something so
they go and get
warriors or people they think are worthy
to fight and they inject them or in
their dna with insect dna yeah
so each one of them has insect
attributes so one of them is like a
praying mantis mixed with a human and so
he can punch really like lightning fast
one of them i think they inject it with
like a flea so they can jump really yeah
yeah yeah yeah and one of and this was
an i was sold one of them got the uh
what is the [ __ ] what's it called it's
the shrimp that can like flick at like
all the punches
yeah yeah it's the manta shrimp that can
break clash by flicking the air yeah
yeah yeah in front of it
and i was like oh [ __ ] i know the men to
strip this badass
and so then they send them to the moon
to go and uh do research and fight back
again
and it's so [ __ ] cool because then it
turns into like a political thing
because obviously if there's [ __ ] on the
moon there's gonna be a lot of countries
arguing about what's going on there and
who did it yeah was this here how many
how many chapters they have
22 volumes okay is it over or is it
still gone
yeah it's a
three years ago yeah and it was still
ongoing yeah was it yeah when did it end
a couple of years ago right 2014. no oh
i think it started in 2014 didn't it it
started 2011. oh [ __ ] where when did it
finish
really there's no way i could have read
everything because when i finished
reading it it was not
done going are they yeah pretty sure are
you sure it's over
either way you need to catch up on yeah
by the way i need to catch up and it was
such a fun manga and if you like one
punch man i think you'll love
terraformers i i'm curious how did you
find terraformers because what's the
anime
i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so sorry
what what convinced you from the anime
to be like i'll read the manga maybe the
blue maybe the manga is better yeah okay
so terraformers had an anime adaptation
and it was notorious for being
absolutely dreadful because what they
did was they made this extremely gory
anime yeah and they were like this is
great let's just censor everything yeah
but they did it in the worst [ __ ] way
they literally put black dots and bars
across the screen so there were some
scenes where you couldn't see anything
it's literally infamous because i
remember one of the first screenshots
yeah because i remember i read some
performance before the anime came out
and i was just like how are they gonna
adapt this because some of these scenes
are pretty like brutal pretty gory
and then i saw that i think the famous
scene is where like the cockroach is
holding someone's head yeah and it's
just like he's just holding a black
circle
because dude this i i'm still convinced
right if this had like a good anime
adaptation like a solid animation like
not one punch man level but close to it
yeah right of the action scenes being
done that well this would be like
[ __ ] oh yeah and that's what i was
looking forward to because i remember i
i got recommended the manga from like
one of my friends who was like dude you
have to [ __ ] with that this is amazing
right i was like oh because could you
imagine the shock people would get when
they're like this there's a scene right
where uh it's very early on so it's not
really a spoiler but one of the scene
because they all the teams drop in
different locations on the moon so you
kind of get like play by place where all
the different teams are on the moon and
one of the scenes where one team just
goes out of the ship and immediately
just they see a flash and someone's lost
their head already yeah yeah and it's
like
hold on [ __ ] and i was like right after
she was injected as well
all right here comes he comes apart
where she kicks us yeah he immediately
dies yeah and it's like oh [ __ ] they're
they're stronger yeah and it's like
everything about this show is so hype
and like reading the manga is like okay
how are they gonna build on this and
they just keep finding ways to make it
more and more interesting yeah it's like
holy [ __ ] and the art style is so cool
honestly honestly
like the manga just never stops kicking
off it's it's like permanently just
kicking off it's really popping off
and if there's not fights there's some
like game of thrones political [ __ ]
going yeah yeah yeah and it's like all
right just as we're on the moon doesn't
mean that china doesn't hate russia like
yeah there's stuff going on yeah it's
like it's so
it's so good and it's yeah and i love
how they introduce like i love it when
shows when there's a lot of characters
that it's like this is the character
this is where they're from this is the
height this is their ability and you're
like sick sick thank you and i can
mentally remember that information
yeah because the the how i discovered
terraformers is moving on to the next
show on your list which is gantz like i
i literally finished dance i was like i
need more shows like yeah it's very
reminiscent i i think it's just like how
brutal and unpredictable like
unpredictable it is in terms of who's
gonna live who's gonna die and i feel
like
it's you know it's it's the meme wedge
where if you can't predict what's gonna
happen or who's gonna die it's like oh
it's gonna like the game of thrones but
like the first time i actually was
like properly shocked at who lived and
who died was [ __ ] gans
which i don't know if how much we can go
into spoilers about gans but
like
you cannot predict who dies
yeah and and the anime was like
it was decent it was pretty solid i feel
like if you are between the ages of like
even though you shouldn't be reading
this for 16 but if you are at the age of
six no no no no no this this is like the
perfect i i think i watched the anime
when i was 16. this is like the most i'm
16 and i want to be experiencing badass
okay there's a scene that happens very
early on right yeah this is quite
graphic um where
so i was explaining the premise right so
against what happens is uh wait wait how
does it very very start it starts with
the the two main characters jumping in
front of a train yeah so oh that's one
yeah yeah yeah so the two characters die
in a train crash or like that scene was
[ __ ] yes yeah so they died pretty
brutally in a train crash um and
afterwards they wake up in this room and
this black
circle has transported to them to this
room along with a lot of [ __ ] along
with other people who have just died and
they're all wearing suits and everyone's
wearing a suit they kind of look like
they're wearing like [ __ ] suits or
whatever suits yeah
and uh they're told that they have to go
kill this alien oh no they they don't
wear the suits that's all the weather
suits yeah they're thought to wear some
people don't want to wear this yeah
it looks it looks like it looks like a
[ __ ] uh it does like a gibson yeah it
does kind of look like a [ __ ] suit right
and there's just a moment in this anime
that either manga it's a slight spoiler
but not really early on uh where
like a girl gets transported in the room
and he's like a teenage boy and he's
like let's have sex and she's like okay
yeah just have sex and you see it you're
like whoa okay what
and they don't they don't do it
terraformers in the animals
in the anime there's literally two sex
scenes in the anime yeah and he just
stopped having sex there in the [ __ ]
hallway of this house and it's like it's
like whoa okay uh i haven't experienced
this before in a manga yeah just [ __ ]
happening all right this is this i don't
even think dogen's gonna get into the
segment
literally just girl appears like do you
wanna have sex because we're dead and
he's like yeah sure yeah
and i remember watching literally
watching dance when i was about like
yeah 15 16. that is the most i'm 16 and
i'm just like oh my god
they're sharing a sex scene
what do you mean
when i read it like last year you know
it's it's one of those shows that
there's nothing quite like it yeah well
this is really fresh holy [ __ ] i haven't
experienced anything like this yeah and
it doesn't hold punches you know and the
whole aspect is that they have to
uh kill these demons that exist in the
human race aliens aliens yeah they they
say that there's been aliens that have
been living in the human world and then
they have to like kill them and so
they're worth points and there's x
amount of points to come back alive yeah
exactly or you know there's there's
different things that they can do with
points right they can bring people who
have died before back to life as well um
the point is that to kill an alien first
you you you think it's like an easy
thing to do yeah but like it's really
really [ __ ] difficult to kill these
aliens and every arc there's a different
alien that they need to kill and there's
a difference
and it gets harder and harder and
progressively like more and more people
will die to the point where you can
never really expect who's going to live
and who's going to die yeah um and i
remember like i feel like
i feel like the peak arc was part two
because it's like separated into three
parts i think yeah i think part two was
the best uh part three had some really
really good moments i feel like there is
a certain climax to gantz that really
like it really it made me
really existential yeah yeah i know
you're on it yeah and without spoiling
two specific details when they find the
creator of these balls
that [ __ ] scene just like i remember
reading the events of that scene and i'm
just like
oh my god this man did like 10 tabs of
lsd yeah
it's it's so it's so like giga brain
existentialism but yeah i mean awkward
have you read anything else by auckland
yeah i i've i know he did the uh ini was
[ __ ] yeah i've heard i know of the
other stuff he's done and it's all
[ __ ] from yeah yeah yeah
the the most recent one he did was this
one called gigant
i've heard of
yeah
it's like giggit and god put together
another just awful uh gig is also just
like i i've started reading it's just
real no it's still going
to take that long
it's really [ __ ] good but it's like
you know it's an okuhiro manga because
it's just [ __ ] there is uh there is
one scene that i will warn you is
extremely questionable uh in the in the
world oh yeah and we spoke about this
before in the podcast extremely
questionable just giving you a heads up
uh yeah it's a little racist they're
quite racist i mean ice shield has a
similar sign yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
we spoke about this before in the
podcast as well but just get a heads up
if you do go into it there is like that
moment yeah um it's very yikes and like
uh okay uh
all right
what i love about gantz and uh
terraformers it's just it's pure bat
[ __ ] insane fun oh yeah yeah it is and
like it's it's kind of like the edgy 16
year old in you but like there are
somebody brings out the 16 year old in
you that thinks like just fighting and
death is badass but like there's there's
like two like kind of different
categories i put this in you know
there's there's like the edgy 16 year
old kind of shows where it brings that
out of you and it remembers what you
felt like when you were 16. and then
there's shows like elf and lead and
mirai nikki
elephant yeah that you watched and i'm
just like damn why the [ __ ] did i ever
enjoy this
yeah i can look back and i'm like that
was good yeah that was a look back i'm
like why was this even remotely popular
i was like i was like
10 out of 10 when i was 16. i'm just
like
was i this easy to trick when i was 16
when i saw blood
when you were 16 this is this is new to
you like yeah this [ __ ] is exciting
you're like whoa
you can do this yeah oh
it's artistic yeah it's just like it's
it's it's crazy yeah i remember a point
when elfin lead was literally when i
joined the community elephant lead was
considered like a modern day classic
yeah i don't know i think
if you thought the anime was good read
the manga because it's like completely
different and i was like all right that
is no different no it is it is very it's
actually more [ __ ] in the manga oh oh
okay but like you know 16 year old aj me
was like how how could they improve on
this and then you read it now and i'm
like
all right yeah i mean i think i've like
watched like full moon alchemist before
it you know yeah yeah yeah then just
going from that where i was like okay
yeah yeah i was like i was like looking
at my monitor on like all like with all
these [ __ ] pop-ups everywhere like
whoa what the [ __ ] you just cut them up
yeah yeah with like ghost arms like what
yeah from i think that like the next
show after elfin lead and miranda was
probably a karmico kill
where
um where i remember he got so [ __ ]
popular and i'm just like i watched the
anime okay that is what i'm 16 yeah i i
am 16 like i i'm i'm 14 and this is deep
yeah i am convinced right okay i like
alpha i know evelyn i like how can i get
killed i'm just gonna say it right now i
like it okay okay i don't care what
people say okay i like it [ __ ] you i
like that did you finish it the anime
yeah yeah
i
i think this will make sense okay this
is how i i view it sure
pov you're a fairy tale fan
you're tired of fairy tale you want
something a little edgier you go
immediately to act make a kill yeah
that's it feels think about it yeah it
is literally fairy tale with but fans
but with way more edge because it feels
like fairy tale in many aspects where
it's like this is dumb dumb [ __ ] why
specifically fairy tales because people
who like make a kill are fairy tale fans
you are right you're all right it is
literally uh if you are a fairytale fan
i bet you love i can make a kill yeah
you are right
think about it think about it say i
agree with seven deadly sins no
but that's that's all kind of the same
seven deadly sins i think people know
it's slightly different i think
so we need to make a chart of like what
you're likely to like based on which
show we just get like
yeah we do right i think i think if if
seven deadly sins is on one end it's
like yeah hunter hunter is on the other
end i think yeah yeah yeah and then what
other shootings are there like i don't
know just like i don't know [ __ ]
seven deadly sin somewhere to me i can't
make a kill is just like the generation
they go into seven deadly sins or fairy
tale and then they also much mirai nikki
and they were like what if we just
combine the two what if we just combine
the two and that and then you get a calm
and go kill when you're like great i you
it you require
even less brain cells to enjoy this
brilliant i i even though i recognized
the ending was [ __ ] dumb for i can
make a kill i liked it i thought it was
fun i had a great time watching that i'm
not afraid to admit just the the plot
twist yeah
yeah it was come the [ __ ] off but i
still had a lot of fun like before that
i had a lot of fun with the show i
really enjoyed it yeah admittedly as
much as i planned on coming to kill
first like five six episodes pretty fun
yeah it's just like brainless fun but
you know what else i read that i read
all of as well well it's remembered now
sorry would you have anything else no no
i'm just gonna say i wrote all of dead
man wonderland oh really yeah oh that's
also i'm succeeded yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is just sure because oh russian
back now
you know what i went on the thing where
i was like the anime ending sucked yeah
i was like i want it i had this uh this
was like two years ago i read it i had
the feeling i was like you know what i
just want to finish and and manga to an
anime that didn't get an ending
announcement okay wonderland yeah and
the manga was definitely better but the
manga had a [ __ ] ending too yeah i mean
not as bad as the anime but it was still
not yeah yeah it was still [ __ ] it was
fine that my wonderland was very five
yeah i think i was exactly the same
because i i finished dead man wonderland
and i like the anime a lot yeah the
anime was great until about episode 10.
yeah and then there's the last couple of
episodes where they're just like oh ran
out of budget yeah yeah basically and so
i was like okay okay i need to see how
this is yeah yeah um so what are we
talking about
do we need to talk about jojo do we
really need to talk about george do you
want to talk about joe apart
to read seven yeah uh i haven't actually
read julian yet but it's about to end as
at the time of uh recording this they
just announced that it's gonna end next
month yeah next month i'm probably gonna
speed run reading to julian yeah
so that i can talk about it
like i'm i think i'm like one volume
behind right now and it's pretty [ __ ]
good so far i'm surprised they're ending
it this
soon though because i'm not gonna go
i've heard that it was not too long ago
that we got introduced to the main
villain so yeah i'm not gonna i don't
wanna
i don't wanna say anything because i
don't know anything that's just what i
know so because everyone was telling me
that it had so much much left but
whatever i'm gonna i'm probably gonna
read it i might make a video about it i
don't know if i should on my main
channel it's pretty good maybe i will
maybe i'll i wouldn't say it's as good
as i think it would be on brand for you
right yeah it'd be on brand for you i in
my opinion it's not as good as like
seven part six or seven but it's up
there it's still pretty good it's jojo
we'll see how we'll see how this uh how
your feelings will change in the news
yeah i mean i don't know like the ending
of jesus might be [ __ ] amazing right
yeah true who knows but yeah jojo i mean
i mean it was the jojo manga that made
you a jojo fan right yeah so it was
definitely i was watching part five
and i wanted more of part five because
it hadn't fully aired yeah we were only
like ten episodes in and i was really
enjoying it
so i went and picked up the manga and i
just [ __ ] loved it like i said such a
great time um
it's a shame that it's the english
official releases are quite slow mm-hmm
um i think we're they just finished
part four
yeah i mean like really yeah oh geez
like a lot of people forget that jojo
just like was this super [ __ ]
underground manga that only like a
select few people really read before the
anime became a thing and so there was
dust yeah in the west and so like there
was just no interest to translate it
officially until the anime came out now
it's weird seeing it become this like
massive one of the most biggest anime
franchises i made a video on what was it
it was like i had this series like back
in the it's like five years ago i had
this series where i would like go into
manga and like kind of find like myths
and like kind of secrets and stuff like
that and kind of talk about it yeah i
remember i made a video on it was part
three oingo boingo and there's that like
you know the moment
i made a video on that five years ago no
views
no views at all i was like oh my god and
that's when i realized i was like oh no
one in the west knows jojo yeah
at that point i feel like jojo was such
a 50 50 on whether it would do well yeah
i think it just i'm really surprised
that it did it just got i think it just
got lucky with the with the memes i
think so yeah it was it was like it was
like so perfected for meme culture that
it was like so ahead of its time yeah
and it's it's really weird because you
it wasn't really memed until part three
yeah yeah the anime came out
i guess i feel like i i did not see
anything about it until part three came
out and then i saw i never stopped uh
seeing the d.o versus jotaro like steam
sale memes you know
you'd see a ton of memes with the aurora
and all that yeah yeah that's when it
really started picking up steam i think
and then it started i then i think the
um people started realizing how good the
anime adaptation was and then part i
remember it really kicked off during
part four yeah airing in the west was
when it started really getting some
steam yeah and then part five just like
insane
yeah the part five anime adaptation of
jojo really like centered into like this
like because the [ __ ] jordano's theme
yeah did numbers for the meme community
oh yeah yeah and jojo in general i mean
how many people got into part jojo in
general
from the journal's team yeah because i
mean
it's like the um what was the undertale
theme uh megalovania
yeah it's it's up there with megalovania
in terms of like obviously it's the
anime community yeah right because think
of like iconic meme music that came out
in the past 10 years what what have you
got there like actual like iconic like
super iconic
theme megalovania there's probably some
other that i'm forgetting yeah
i think that was joking there wasn't
really an explosion of like jojo never
exploded you just slowly crept up in
popularity until you couldn't you
couldn't like it was inescapable yeah
i've really helped since part five
started airing it really blew up yeah i
feel like a noticeable change yeah in my
opinion part five is probably one of the
only parts where it's actually better in
the anime yeah yeah part four i think
you can go either all part four was yeah
either three three two and one hundred
percent the market yeah
i think part three was like dragged out
too much in the anime yeah you can
speedrun it yeah
you could be like all right
obviously don't do that but you can you
can get through it at a good pace yeah
um but the part three of the anime is
very slow which i think jojo in general
is better in manga also because you have
part six and seven which are very good
part seven being especially notorious
for being just amazing
part seven is possible is amazing part
seven is where i feel like iraqi really
came into his own and finally made like
the perfect jojo part where there was no
pacing issues yeah i feel like every
part of jojo had some kind of weird
pacing at some point or another every
character was fun and like memorable
yeah like so so for example like part
three it drags out a bunch part two is
very short and sweet you don't really
get too much but it's very nice and
that's why part two is i mean joseph's
the only redeeming factor about that
the villain's boring yeah right part one
i mean it's no touristy
it's quite boring i won't lie it has a
lot of charm as a jojo but at least it's
short all right it's very short you can
read through it part four
kira who is the arguably one of the best
villains in jojo isn't there for the
first half so you kind of get a slice of
life for the first part which is which
is fun but it takes a while for it to
kind of find its footage yeah if if
you're not a fan of that kind of stuff
then
you can easily like fall off it yeah and
be like why is this popular yeah why do
people like this um plot five is very
solid uh i think that uh jordana is one
of the weaker joe joe bros uh joe joe
pros jojo's um you know bootstrap really
does carry oh yeah yeah yeah um and then
part six you know it's good it also has
a bit of a controversial ending um i
really like i like it but some people
don't like it i can understand why
people wouldn't like it i feel that some
parts of part six are a little weak but
part seven is like from start to finish
banger every single character banger
like the villains even like the side
villains i mean it is it does have kind
of the least memorable jojo's though uh
johnny uh yeah i don't know i feel like
johnny doesn't get good till like the
last quarter maybe johnny comes into his
own yeah yeah but i feel like jono
doesn't really come into his own no at
any point no sorry if we're going on a
whole talk about jojo um watch or read
jojo just just talk about it jojo fans
being jojo fans exactly right you need
to read it because then you can
experience part 7 which you should 100
read it is amazing no you can't skip to
it don't do that yeah because part 7 has
so many references to previous parts
you'd be spoiling it read it all it's
amazing yeah yeah uh all right what else
feelings are vinyl and saga did you put
this on your list or not or we're gonna
get it i uh i didn't put this on my list
oh okay yeah i almost did but then i was
like yeah the anime is out villain saga
gets to go on my list wonks the banger
two because they uh spell a welsh town
correctly
yeah it's got one of the most badass
like antagonists in like manga and he's
welsh yeah welsh as well of course i i
didn't i knew you would love this skull
lads
represent represent they went to like
somewhere and that i was so glad that
they i want i really want to because
obviously i read it in english yeah i
really want to see how they spelled this
welsh town yeah
like because it's like it was like
or something right yeah and i was like
how the [ __ ] do you how the how on earth
do you
i don't remember how i'm pretty sure i
got up to that part but i don't remember
how they spelled it i really want to see
how they spelled it i was like oh that's
a funny name because how on earth did
you put the sound they probably don't
they probably didn't yeah they already
did yeah they probably did like
but uh yeah though honestly memes aside
um vinyl and saga is amazing like i
think even if
i had read more than 10 manga
it would still be on there it is so
[ __ ] good it's on hiatus and it's
still amazing is it on hiatus yeah isn't
it i don't know i think i i feel like
it's still i read up to a certain point
i caught up and then i stopped yeah what
what is it about like all these like
sane and manga the sane in classics i i
would like to call them that just
eventually goes
masterpieces always go on yeah saying
that masterpiece is always going to go
on hiatus right and it's just villain
saga is just amazing and like
the you when you realize it's a [ __ ]
prologue the first arc is just a
prologue yeah and yet it's still one of
the best stories okay
what do you think for because if you've
seen season one villain saga you know
what the prologue is you know what the
main are the main beginning arc is what
do you think of the farmland arc
i really like the farmland
i'm excited to see the reactions
so the farmland
okay so we won't talk too much about it
we'll spoil it but it changes the pace
drastically yeah if okay so if you think
that if you go into season two thinking
that it's going to be in the same vein
of season one you're going to be
disappointed the way i find a feel about
it right right is that
berserk and villain saga they have a
crossroads and they both went different
ways with it yeah yeah whereas you know
for example guts right never stops
becoming violent yeah god's argument
becomes more violent every time yeah
yeah and you know vinland saga tries to
make a character that maybe feels a
little bit more guilty about that yeah
and so that's what was really
interesting for me is that they weren't
just like okay this guy's good at
killing yeah that's what he does now
yeah he just keeps killing he's like no
he he actively like he matures he
doesn't want to keep doing that that's
and that's what's so interesting about
it and really recommend reading it it is
just amazing it's like a huge artistic
risk he took with that oh yeah i think
it paid off
it's like his the the worst thing he did
was making the prologue so [ __ ] good
like like imagine that being the worst
thing you could do you made it so
[ __ ] good that people expected you to
keep doing that yeah yeah and it's like
he he keeps doing it but in a completely
different type of story yeah because
it's like villain saga is [ __ ]
incredible but like the prologue is so
different than the rest of the story
that if you come into it with the same
expectations you're gonna just get
whiplash you're gonna be like where's
the action where's the killing where's
the violence there was so much of this
in season one and i was just like well
once you've realized that the story was
never about that that the story was all
about
they were building it up the whole time
yeah when you realized that everything
that his father said at the beginning
was what the story was meant to be about
from the from the get-go and everything
else was just like everything else was
like a bigger tangent than anything that
we've ever gone on yeah you know and
that was yeah yeah season one's just a
time but it's so true to life because
even if your dad told you [ __ ] you
wouldn't [ __ ] listen to him yeah but
then you'll realize when you're an adult
he was right all along exactly that's
right
i'm sorry i went against you father it's
so good because it's so like even though
the situation's obviously crazy but even
though it's not that unbelievable
because you know it's it's set on like a
real part of history yeah you know
it it builds characters in such a
compelling way that are so realistic and
every single character in this show
you're like i believe that could be a
dude yeah yeah i believe that i i see
parallels to myself and some of these
characters that are uncomfortable yeah
and that's what i loved about it it was
so good and it presented war in a
horrific way yeah as war should be yeah
and so if you haven't please do yourself
a solid and and read vineland
it is amazing
if you like vikings i just just you know
just just at least read if ask a lads or
at least watch the anime for asking
because he is honestly like i think one
of my favorite characters oh yeah
oh he's straight up my guy and also i
mean
i'm very excited for the reaction to
anime fans and my only fans to the
season
two yeah to be like hey when does when
does stuff happen
so how long are they going to how long
are they going to stay on this farm it
goes from like doom to runescape in like
like one chapter it's like it's like
it's like doomed it's like
like stardew valley or something like
that i guess that's spoilers enough
right yeah i mean berserk we've we
literally just talked about berserk yeah
it's a classic for a reason i've spoke
about claymore before yeah um claymore
again is uh very similar to i guess
berserk in some ways yeah i'm stock fans
would you say you enjoyed it enough that
if you had read more manga you think you
would still be in yours i don't think it
would be on here if i'd read
some other big names that i know i would
enjoy
um i think it's got a benga first half
yeah and then loses its steam yeah you
know there's some stories where you're
reading the manga and you're like this
[ __ ] planned everything yeah
like a blueprint yeah yeah he knew
exactly what was gonna happen and he
knew exactly where this was going
whereas with claymore i feel like
they would he was
they were just writing it and he had a
core idea and he just didn't or they i
don't know if it's a guy or a girl yeah
uh they just didn't really know how they
wanted to finish it but that that's
that's the i believe george armada talks
about this there's two ways of writing
stories and there's the architect and
the uh
something like something to do with like
growing plants or something yeah yeah
one likes to design everything like a
building you have every single aspect
like out perfectly and the other it's
like a greenhouse you just kind of grow
things see where it goes see what goes
with it i definitely feel like that is a
riskier way of doing stories but also
can lead to some super interesting
results yeah and i feel like claymore
just kind of lost and i feel like the
the architect like type is like the the
downside to it is like you could build
too much and then you kind of have to
like oh should i have to pick up all
these right here
maybe you build too much of the world
yeah sometimes it's a bad thing i mean
you can pull up
right just like hunter hunter introduced
like seventeen thousand things yeah
there is it's just harder to maintain
yeah exactly
breaks down and you put more bricks down
and then you forget the foundations you
laid yeah you start building a chimney
where you've already built like a
fireplace on the other side it doesn't
make it like any sense something except
maybe i'm running out of bricks i don't
know how much time left my back hurts i
can't draw [ __ ] i should have thought
about this or you could just be like a
rocky and just be like yeah i'm just
gonna plant the scene here and see how
it goes which is what i love about he
that is the perfect example of that kind
of writer iraqi literally just gives you
ideas and then he just keeps expanding
on it yeah and you can tell he has some
idea where he wants it to go but you can
tell also
you can tell there's so many moments
where he just like and he even says it
himself right when he just decides to do
things he doesn't remember half the [ __ ]
he wrote
it's such a fun way and it leads to such
fun writing yeah 100 but yeah claymore
although
an amazing concept amazing first half
yeah definitely and the art is so good
you're beyond that that's amazing yeah
it's one of the best [ __ ] love what
is it what is it about dark fantasy
where just the art is just always about
i don't know it's it's it's like a rite
of passage right oh you want to write a
dark fantasy show me your drawings you
better have godly and for some reason
i'm a simple man um i like rankings so
whenever there's characters and they
have ranks
and like
a true gamer they're clearly defined as
this is number one strong this is number
two strong i don't know why i love that
but you're a gamer yeah because it's
like i mean i i feel like there's just
something embedded into like yeah humans
that i just like rankings we love
ranking things yeah and i love and then
the story aspect of number seven could
actually be stronger than number two
yeah in some ways and that's super
interesting why you like one punch man
i love the hero rating system
i think it leads to such interesting
like characters in really strange ways
um like yeah i love the bicycle man in
there yeah i mean that's just why that's
just part of like showing an anime right
we need to rank people because people
like ranks people like i love it what
what are the what are the youtubers
going to make videos about if we can't
[ __ ] rank exactly right in japanese
companies you get ranked on your
performance yeah with a rank and uh like
a grade i want to be number one yeah so
like it's it's like they they love doing
it everything needs to be ranked here
like a bidet rank
what i love is how everyone's just found
out like
power ranking things just like people
just you could power rank the most
mundane things
this is why it's here this is literally
what tealistic yeah it's literally just
powerful yeah yeah yeah um and then
obviously i shield 21 which is uh i've
watched crocodile basket i i've read
i've watched your mushy pedal uh what
other sports anime have fans
i've watched haikyuu slam dunk i haven't
read slam dunk i'm gonna read slam dunk
but so far this is my favorite sports
story oh yes yes it's awesome and again
like the visual this single-handedly got
me into american football yeah i i still
don't know the rules fully yeah um but i
had a fun time i mean it's very deviated
from real life it is i'm like i'm
watching real american football and i'm
just like where are the metaphors
where where
you're not gonna lie like i was like oh
you know when i when i read this because
i was like in the prime of my childhood
when this was in show and jump right so
everyone like everyone was trying to
like do rodeo drives and like double
that ghost
this is the one move that is probably
like the most feasible
if i ever throw a football ever again
you bet i'm gonna like picture a [ __ ]
angel behind him
there's a panel where like he throws
this ball and it's like this amazing
artwork of like this angel yeah the
angel throw or something
this panel it's like a spread and it's
[ __ ] beautiful yeah yeah and it's
just oh it's so good i think some of the
best is where you see the battle of the
metaphors and i think it just makes the
it makes the sport scene so much more
hype
because i can't remember the exact
because it's been years and years um but
i remember like very vividly just
someone kicking a ball and it just like
it it's kicked with like so much force
or something that it like penetrates
something that's
[ __ ] i'm i'm speaking what was like the
second to last match what was like the
last match was against the best school
yeah they were like the best school in
japan yeah because that's was probably
the highlight of it and then afterwards
they fight america
that's right oh yeah and that was kind
of that kind of sucked yeah but yeah
they go against like the best players
yeah the real number seven the real
number the real 21 21 21 [ __ ] house
the real high shots
yeah
sorry i don't know if that's spoilers
that might be spoiler actually
mulan spoiler warning put this before
uh yeah yeah it's brilliant yeah they
they face the the real i shield 21. all
right and as they all have interesting
powers yeah that it's literally it's
literally crocodile basket
on the field
i think uh the guy who wrote eyeshield
21 went on to do another shonen jump
manga dr stone yeah he wrote dr stone
right yeah
that's right yeah i remember that
very good very good storytelling very
different i just yeah i like that all
these all these i would honestly and all
these are very very solid shows i mean
it's it's like it kind of gives off the
vibe of just like yeah i've only read
nine manga which you you kind of have at
least you've read nine great
you've read like nine great margins
thank you thank you good taste assuming
the bottom left is replacement
it's amazing
yeah and this one you can read on
bookwork or listen to your book walker
as well
i guess it's kind of good you went first
because i guess you can listen to some
of mine and joey's recommendations or
like some of our favorite manga i mean
i'm not going to say i recommend
everyone that's on my three bites yeah
me neither
but uh there are definitely some
recommendations that i think everyone
should read on my 3x3
show so shall we move on to who's next
this episode is sponsored by book walker
what does daddy walker have for us today
oh i'll tell you what daddy has daddy
added two new titles to the exclusive
catalog did you know two brand new
exclusives that's right bibi and you
won't believe it one of them is a full
color volume of why the hell are you
here tasha wow i couldn't possibly miss
out on the student teacher action in
full color joey what is this about well
i'll tell you why the hell you hear
teacher is a lewd manga series depicting
the awkward relationships between
students and their teachers who keep
getting into awkwardly embarrassing
situations inevitably developing an
interest for each other by exploring the
appeals of a grown woman's body did you
get all that now that sounds spicy the
second title they've brought to us today
is the brand new series called she's
adopted a high school boy am i dreaming
to milf manga in one day i know how
excited you are about that connor indeed
she's adopted a high school boy brings a
wholesome story of a high school student
and the lady living next door to him who
decides to mysteriously adopt him after
he's left behind by his parents with a
mountain of depth now i want to know
more right then what are you waiting for
right now until the end of august you
can get up to 50 off all these titles on
bookwalker plus you can get 15 coinback
and all eligible titles in their
exclusive fair promotion also if you're
a digital collector you'll be happy to
find that purchasing volume one of the
ebooks included in this promotion will
also come with brand new bookshelf cover
images for your collection did you get
all that i don't know i didn't but guys
guys don't forget to follow bookwalker
on twitter at bookwalker underscore gl
for the latest information on new manga
titles and special promotions thank you
daddy book walker back to the
episode next manga three by three and we
have beer yeah we have beer
this just appears cheers boys
cheers cheers oh it's been a very
civilized three by three so far but i
mean what can we complain about this
honestly normie yeah
is it normie though
i kinda i'd say it's pretty normal
i don't know man
listen ain't nothing wrong with a bit of
boy's love you know that's as normal as
it gets who's next
which of you wants to go next
i don't mind going next you don't want
you don't want to get it i don't mind
going next all right let's see what joey
has to say this might be oh no okay why
is that so tight
hold on
joey oh it's me oh okay i actually
thought this was gone
i could have sworn i folded god's tiny
that no this is not fixed i just
i'm just saying
you're exposing us connor you're
exposing us scripted
this is joey too
it was destiny there was two shows that
was not me
i swear we did not when i asked he
wanted to go next i that was not fixed
this is like the google when people
search up what is goku's real name
it was rigged but whatever we'll have
joey's up next i guess oh
okay do i know all of these okay let me
try and guess this all right so berserk
obviously i guess you put jojoba six
specifically yeah i like part 6
specifically
um
do you know this one is that is that
misa from death note
is it
do you recognize i kind of recognize
this
is the assassins thing assassin's thing
no that's hitman reborn
no this is this was a [ __ ]
it's a shonan it's shiny jump yeah black
cat it's black
i've seen the anime black yes very good
is it mr manga good yeah it's [ __ ]
awesome wait why did the anime suck dick
i don't know i didn't watch the anime
what the hell this is
here
this is a manga three by three i've seen
this i think
this is this is the line rider right
that mini clutch
he's the main character
yeah he's the main character and
everyone else is a normally drawn
character yeah okay and then yeah
and then slam dunk be stars
um joe love room
we bought the whole collection of
television recently right yeah
accidentally
you want to explain the story
yeah
so i got scammed quote unquote so i
bought uh i bought
all the volumes of boba bo which was one
that i thought about putting up here um
but it was only volume one and four
though so basically i opened up volume
one and it was uh i bought a second hand
so i was like okay i was whatever it was
chiefs or whatever and i was like all
right cool i'm gonna relieve my
childhood open up volume one of bobo
it's volume three of 12
they just literally replaced the cover
they literally just put the cover
of bobo
on the front of this but it's volume
three of the locker room did you reckon
they did it on purpose or an accident i
reckon it's by accident so i was like
wait don't tell me all of these at all
for some reason volume one and four was
so so it's probably just you know you
know when you like take a dvd out to
watch it and you have to put the dvd in
the dvd player back in the box yeah i
think you forget that you've just like
yeah
was owned by like a teenager and it was
like well i need to hide the
degenerative [ __ ] from my mom i'm going
to put the bow before oh my god that was
totally it wasn't it was slowly yeah
like they'll never know we'll never know
we'll never know i just think it's
barbara some kids jacked off dior
volume 1. i'm trying to throw that out
uh is this junji ito so that's uzumaki
oh yeah it's this i'd be surprised you
know it's ichigo 100 oh it's itchy i've
heard of this i have not read it or
watched it okay um so which one would
you like to know first obviously we i
think we can get rid of uh
again jojo because we've already talked
about that already talked about that so
not hunter hunter okay
i i i'm probably going to get destroyed
okay okay i haven't read hontanti yet oh
okay wait i've watched it and it's
amazing yeah the only reason why i i
think the biggest takashi sim hasn't
read
so much about hunter hunter
just from outside information but i
haven't actually read it or watched it i
i own all the volumes right now i think
it's sitting there waiting for off for a
rainy day i think it's i think it's safe
to say this it's the best show to
animate i feel like a lot of people say
that i feel like i've been lied to
because the amount of times we talk
about hunter hunter and me and connor
have just like been talking about the
dark continent
we always mean like netro getting up
i just i just always assumed that joey
was just like
literally all the information i know is
because people around me don't stop
talking about that it's not okay you
need to go watch it what the [ __ ] or
read it the anime is amazing i never
said i read it or watched it
i just assumed the anime man had watched
hunter hunter
i feel like this has just been a game of
among us now
[ __ ] impossible there's an impossible
among us
so much about hunter like i could
probably like give you the outline of
how it goes but i don't know what the
names of the arcs i want to go back to
every clip now
i know like dark content and our camera
and arc all of those the hunter exam arc
and all that
i know them again because i hear it from
everybody
what i want to know is how we've just
found out about this despite the fact
that we've talked about it so many times
on the podcast is this publicly known is
this widely available information yeah
you've like been a part of the
conversation i swear to god i don't know
we're gonna have to like rewind every
clip where we've talked about hundreds
i've said it on i've said it on streams
multiple times i've never read or
watched it i i can't be there for the
whole three hours
but yeah like again i know so much about
hunter and i know i'm gonna like it
that's why i'm not in a rush to read it
or watch it because i don't know okay i
like it yeah me and full metal outcomes
yeah it's like it's like of course it's
like we've just found joey's full
message it's like it's takashi
i know and again like i know it's going
to be good because i love togashi yeah
it's [ __ ] amazing i don't know
don't read it watch the anime
the animals the anime is better do you
agree
uh
yeah because i've heard both sides of
the argument listen what's the other
side of the argument the other side is
that the manga is good because togashi
is good
i mean that's so it's so it's basically
just like a preference in medium then
right pretty much yeah i mean yeah i
mean i'm probably gonna watch and read
both to be honest it's it's just a
matter of which one to do first yeah i
mean hanzonz is just prime mad house and
madhouse haven't been at the prime for
like a long time i think yeah and the
manga also looks like napkin drawings a
lot of the time not
in the beginning and the volumes the
volumes are fixed oh so they fix it yeah
in the shonen jump volumes uh the
magazines it looks like [ __ ] okay but
then he redraws it for the actual i
finished the anime and then
carried on reading and i was like
am i reading like one web comic right
now like what what is this it was about
that uh drawing honestly it's yeah but i
yeah wow yeah but then he takes the time
to actually redraw everything properly
for the actual book so the books look
like [ __ ] amazing sense but also kind
of sad if you're a big hunter hunter fan
who waits and then you have to go back
and read it but yeah if you read it if
you read a week like you're probably
yeah it's like a weekly
um so that's your favorite shonen jump
title of course well i mean here's the
thing uh a lot of these are shortages
yeah so i kind of realized that what's
black cat doing show black cat slam dunk
each other 100 jojo
oh yeah i want to let's talk let's talk
about you hack show because i've i've
ever watched i think i mentioned on the
podcast one time i tried to start it
yeah i just could i couldn't stand the
audio on the on the i don't know oh so
you watch the anime i watch five minutes
oh i can't take this so you hug show it
it does like uh what i like to call a
reborn basically it starts off as a
comedy ends up as an action right same
thing with dragon ball right like dragon
ball started off as a comedy and then z
came along and it became the action that
it's known for so like right you hawks
are the first couple of arcs like when
you scared the main character dies like
it's kind of like a scene that's how it
starts right yeah
it's not literally first panel you skate
our main character gets hit by a car and
dies
this was before isa car was the thing
yeah he didn't go to another world he
just he just died he just died
i know a lot about you hack a show
without ever watching it yeah right i
know a lot of i know the bad guy i know
there's an epic fight with one guy i
don't know who it is and then yeah
cause you know the tournament arc right
i know the tournament
he literally just described literally
every shonen anime of all time i know
the bad guy i know there's another
i know what he looks like i know who
it's going to be and the giga shadow
yeah what's his name i don't know giga
chad
giggart
yeah i don't think he he's even the best
villain he looks like the uh you know if
you watch very odd parents
crimson chin he looks like yeah you know
like have you watched very often the
buff fairy right yeah he looks like the
buff fairy from very high
looks like the buff fairy from from
fairly odd parents
oh my god
he has the muscles but like the weird
neck yeah yeah it's literally like the
fairy art parents
he looks exactly like that oh my god
look but
ruined one of the pictures of the
villain villains
all right so like so have you ever seen
the anime of yuhaka show i have
not not a fan not a fan not a fan is it
it's i don't know it's bittersweet right
because it's like the same thing with
black cat where it's like i love the
manga so much that like
it wasn't like the perfect adaptation
that i wanted like it was good but it's
like i'd rather just reread them what
was it what was missing to make it the
perfect adaptation
as someone who's like i haven't read the
manga of you hakusho i've only seen the
anime oh really yeah oh did you like the
anime i [ __ ] love the anime well
you'd [ __ ] love the manga even more
okay but like is there anything i can
get from the manga that i couldn't have
already gotten from the anime or just
re-watch the animation because i thought
the anime was like a really good
adaptation especially for history like
records of red rock
that's better than that that's solid
animation you know
i mean i don't know like i think this
might just be like the the whole thing
with like how manga art styles i feel
age better than animation in a lot of
aspects yeah in my eyes
to differ you think so like demon slayer
in the manga it just looks terrible
compared to the animal well i mean
that's because like the animations
the character designs change differently
right but like in the anime adaptation
of you hawk show they did a pretty good
job of like
re-adapting like uh togashi's art style
i feel like i haven't read it from what
i've just seen of it it looks one-to-one
to me i don't know i'll just a glance
that's like a person who's i don't know
i feel blanched it but i i sometimes
look at clips of the anime of you haksha
and i'm like something about this hasn't
aged
chinese 90s yeah it's 90s like the 90s
animation is
some of it hasn't aged very well
yeah i mean some some of it's like very
janky limited animation this is like a
90s anime yeah but like they still had
like when during the big fights there
are still like those sakuraga moments
absolutely like those have aged
wonderfully i mean i i honestly think at
this point it's just like a personal
preference like the same thing with slam
dunk right it's like slam dunk for me
like i watch the anime as well like a
[ __ ] banger of an anime but it's like
i just personally prefer the manga to be
honest i actually have like huge
problems with that slam dunk anime i
think that's age horrible i've heard
that sounding amazing very good and
that's because it might be a nostalgia
factor yeah it's probably his nostalgia
factor because i watched it in
university and i was just like man this
is a it's a really slow sports anime my
[ __ ] god they literally like take ten
episodes it's like it's like a hundred
times
sports anime sorry sports shows uh sorry
support support properties in general
uh almost better in manga normally like
i just just because of pacing yeah i i
think that that's true like 10 years ago
or 20 years ago now
um because like slam dunk i shield i
would like recommend the mango
yeah
that's that's why for me like both slam
dunk and you yeah in my manga three by
three not my anime yeah yeah yeah like i
much prefer the mangroves yeah because
like i i feel like old sports anime they
had horrible pacing but like shows like
haikyuu kuroko actually your mushy pedal
i really am yeah yeah
like they i think i think within the
past like new generation sports i mean
they've really fixed their pacing issues
to the point where if a match lasts more
than three episodes then it's like a
super super important match like have
you seen haikyuu uh i've watched the
first two seasons okay so season three
is like one single match it's like
yeah and when i saw that i was like
here we [ __ ] go again another another
like dragon ball z esque fight scene in
a in like in a sports anime but like
that match was so [ __ ] intense that
it needed 10 episodes and like it was
just what it was not stretched out at
all yeah at all and that was like to me
like the highlight of haikyuu so far of
the anime i enjoyed crocodile basket i
thought the i enjoyed the posting on
that even if yeah because it was very
quite fast really yeah i think it was
like actually good pacing because it was
like never more than three episodes yeah
because how many times how like i can
only be invested in one match for like
so long you know
there's only so much that can happen in
a single match well i was really good at
building up the [ __ ] i think yeah
yeah you're like what do you mean you
know they they weren't rushing too much
into like the powers yeah they were
pretty sparingly adding them in i felt
and then i i didn't watch the movie but
everything the movie was everything
passed the main
run of the what is it three seasons two
seasons three seasons three yeah three
after the how many is that 50 episodes
something like that i guess over 50
episodes yeah it's where they beat the
uh the
does it end oh it doesn't matter but the
point was that i found that after like
that that was like not really invested
anymore it's such a shame for me because
like from the i didn't watch all of
kuroko like but
from what i did see
i really enjoyed it but it sucks because
for me now slam dunk is just like
forever just ruined basketball and i i
wonder if i will read slam dunk and i'll
feel like i can't enjoy this croakers
better or if i'll feel that like there's
definitely been both cases so like i've
i've recommended slam dunk to people who
first read kuroko yeah and they were
like ah it's not as good because they're
just used to the kuroko format because
like unlike kiroko slam dunk doesn't
have any like super powers it is like
it's just very bare bones raw it's like
an nba jam versus nba 2k yeah yeah
you're pretty much pretty much yeah like
it kind of like it kind of like takes
the fact that it is probably one of the
most realistic adaptations of sports in
manga yeah but it still makes it just as
exciting but it does it in the most like
cinematic like [ __ ] type of way and i
mean like you know in the case of slam
dunk like when that first came out of
japan that it created a [ __ ] cultural
phenomenon well every time i have an old
taxi man here and he asked me if i like
anime or whatever i'll be like yeah i
like anime and then he's like oh do you
like slam dunk they always ask me yeah
they're in the like 40s plus they always
ask me if i like yeah it was like a
cultural phenomenon here in japan wasn't
it when it came out i think i think the
year that it came out i think i read
something like uh of all like middle
schools and high schools in japan the
attendance of basketball clubs raised by
six hundred percent well that's not a
huge sport in japan as well yeah but it
wasn't but it got bigger
yeah yeah i mean it was that good i mean
in my opinion
the final chapter of slam dunk is still
one of the most beautiful chapters in
all of manga yeah i mean
he had balls to just put zero dialogue
yeah the entire last chapter has zero
dialogue yeah i'll get that one and it
just stands and it is the most cinematic
final chapter of manga ever in my
opinion but i mean like yeah so i mean
obviously that's great um so black cat
all right so black cat for me
okay so you know how my character like
my avatar on youtube
yeah oh so that came from black guy from
black oh my god okay so yabba ki kentar
who's the guy who made black cat he has
this thing in all of his manga so he
also illustrated to love her as well
yeah um
i mean it is [ __ ] good but um he has
this like kind of easter egg thing in
all of his manga where in every chapter
of his manga he puts this like little
white cat in at least one panel of every
chapter of his vlogger just as like a
little hidden easter egg and it's that
cat face that i use as my mask so like
originally like [ __ ] back way back
when on like new grounds and [ __ ] like
that that was just my logo oh and then
and then it adapted into my current
avatar but like i don't know black cat
was like
it's weird it's definitely heavy
nostalgia factor but i think this was
the first time i ever read a manga and i
was like wow
like manga artists are [ __ ] talented
it was the first time where i was
actually wowed by a piece of artwork you
want to explain what happens in it i i
can try and explain but i honestly can't
remember anything it's been a while yeah
it's been a while for me as well
you want to try this
he's not a black cat no but that's like
his code name yeah he's an assassin
right he's an assassin yeah he's number
13. that's it
and his name is train he has two guns
train heartness this is two guns oh is
that it yeah train hardness train hard
two guns two guns yeah he has two guns
two pistols yeah
sven
i remember that this was the first
because i just got into anime i'd say
anything i remember about it this is the
first show that i was like yeah you know
what not every anime is above a seven
uh this is the first show that i was
like i'm gonna teach you a lesson as an
example to the other animals right five
you know what i mean like i gave it a
lower score than i would have just to be
like yeah you know what i'm saying
that's the proof of point i'll give out
first goals yeah sorry okay give it five
because i didn't i i think i remember
watching like a few episodes of black
cat years ago and it was just me it was
just that phase where you'd watch
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
i was like cool guy in the black coat he
looks kind of cool i watched a few
episodes and it was just like wow
so what happens extremely well so
black cat is like he kind of uh so train
obviously he starts off as this like
assassin but then he escapes from the
organization that he's part of and he
basically the entire manga he gets
chased by the organization members come
back to the organization because he has
like all the syrians or whatever yeah
and like there's a dude in the
organization or i think who also left
the organization who is like he's
basically like the quintessential male
yonder
like it's really like i remember the the
main bad guy is like i don't know i've
never really heard of like a male
yandere antagonist before in a manga
yeah especially in the show no matter i
just realized out of context you kind of
sound like you're describing john wick
or something it's like he left the
organization and he isn't there he's an
assassin yeah this is just gold coins
they killed his dog
he killed his black cat
[Music]
but yeah basically and then like sven is
the guy who like has like uh he's like
an explosives expert and then eve is
this uh he's like this she's like this
test tube like experimental this is when
every single manga had to have like a
rag tag band of
uh people who could yeah
special things yeah and have comedy okay
so why is this in your 3x3 i'm so cute
it's in my 3x3 because it was one of the
first manga okay so when i was growing
up reading manga i obviously started off
reading things like doraemon and like
you know the quarter quarter comic
magazine which is more aimed towards
kids under the age of 10 years old right
then when i got to around 10 11 years
old i was like oh you know what throw
him on quarter quarter stuff
it's a bit too young for me i've got a
big pp now i'm i'm a big i'm a big boy
now i'm i'm about to enter middle school
right i want to read some some of this
middle school
dance
so i was like you know i want to read
this like shonen jump thing that i keep
hearing all my japanese friends talking
about yeah so at the time i borrowed one
of my friends shonen jump magazines yeah
and i think that particular magazine
black cat was on the cover of it oh okay
because black cat had like because like
every month and every week on show and
jump that happens
yeah they change the cover you know some
chapters have like you know colored
pages and some of them are like have
like center colors and stuff like that
and i think black cat had a front color
chapter
and yeah again like you know you go from
darymon to this right like clearly this
is going to make you go whoa
what the [ __ ] is that and so
yeah and i think like honestly
i really enjoyed it i mean yama kentaro
i think still makes some [ __ ] godly
character designs i mean you know the
reason why tolava is so [ __ ] infamous
is because like the character designs
[ __ ] cute like he knows how to draw
really just aesthetic looking characters
and like you know black cat i feel was
definitely when he was still kind of in
his like younger times where like he
hadn't quite refined his art but near
the end of black cat his art just got
better and better and better and better
and like okay i don't know
it's just like a it's nothing like deep
or anything or like profoundly in any
way it's just a really solid
um with like really just intricate nice
arts does it hold up today
you know what i haven't read it in quite
a while i did would you recommend it to
someone to read now
it's hard
it's really hard
because like i don't know because i'm
obviously looking at this shirt because
this show is very
nostalgic it's very nostalgic i'm
obviously looking at this with like
roasting glasses yeah yeah yeah so like
i don't know maybe if you're a fan of
like yellow cantor stuff like if you
liked you know what you saw in tolava
okay and one like that with action does
it is the story does it kind of wrap up
does that have a good conclusion yeah it
does actually it has a really nice
conclusion and like the the final fight
with like the the male yandere
antagonist who's a really [ __ ]
interesting character and the powers in
everything like super cool yeah um yeah
i don't know it's again it's just like a
really solid shonen jump manga that's
like very inoffensive i feel like i
think this is the start of the time
where i start to realize anime
anime sometimes just don't have endings
well because i started off with death
note code yeah alchemist i'm like sick
these are great
you you spoiled yourself you literally
spoiled all of anime for yourself oh no
i did not had a great time
because what i mean is that no no other
anime that just is a normal anime he's
just going to live up to those standards
yeah exactly yeah so then i started
watching shows i'm like wait
why didn't this end where's the ending
and this one this is when this is how
you know everyone else had the same
desperation as me because you whenever
you type in the show the first autofill
is when is season three coming out of
this show literally there are no plans
for season three of this show literally
when you get like when you type in no
game no life
because everyone's like wait why would
that not be a season two this is a
popular show right
there's season two coming right right
right never happened yeah and then this
is when i started to realize i'm like oh
they're just not going to finish shows
they're just going to like release shows
they're just going to be like we
released it we're not going to finish it
[ __ ] you guys i'm sorry sometimes i wish
anime was produced by americans because
you know that it would [ __ ] end it
might not be good but you know it's
coming out that's why i feel like manga
takes more of the same form as like
american tv shows because some markets
just go on for [ __ ] ever and like
you're just like you know i'm not i
don't know if i'm even invested to see
this end anymore right like this then
anime will make like a billion dollars
and they're like no i don't think we
need another no there's no more
sometimes sometimes an anime makes like
a billion dollars but then it's like one
hundredth of the entire story and you're
just like
how like how they ever gonna adapt the
entire story it's gonna take like
[ __ ] 10 decades to do this
and so you know there are some stories
where i'm just like i i just i know i'm
never going to see the end of the anime
and even like manga form
like i'm still waiting like [ __ ]
hippo like
how long is ippo going to go on for sure
right like jesus yeah obaki right like
you should go on favorites yeah
i should go on forever but speaking of
bucky obviously bucky's the [ __ ]
sense his daughter yeah b stars [ __ ]
amazing that's that's like the newest
one that's on that's probably the newest
one like i after i finished reading b
stars i was like oh that is so close to
a modern masterpiece how come uh in
terms of manga i come back here isn't on
here
bucky i don't know
like for me bucky is one of those shows
where it's like
it's good don't get me wrong it's
[ __ ] amazing and it's so unique yeah
yeah but
i feel that it's like there are some
parts where it's just like
it's just a blur when you read it you
know what i mean or it's like it's so
long and there's so much [ __ ] that
happens in it that is just so insane and
ridiculous that you you think of one
fight scene and it blends in with about
10 other fighters that's just true it's
true right like part two for example
right with the whole tournament yeah
like i'm just like i can only remember
maybe like one or two fights i re-write
at the other side there's like 20 fights
in the manga yeah in the enemy then you
showed like four yeah right well that's
pretty because most of them were kind of
underwhelming yeah true true a lot of
the fight even in the anime there was
only then you should like six and i was
like ah three like with bucky you
remember the most like notable like meme
were the ridiculous type of scenes right
whereas with uh b stars for example it's
like
just as like one cohesive story it was
just a really [ __ ] unique yeah really
done well and it's just yeah has it
concluded yep it ended when did it
finish it could have been too long about
a year ago so how many seasons of the
anime do you think there
should be if we were to adapt everything
to adapt everything yeah so
we're at season two right now which is i
should probably shouldn't say
where we're up to in season two but
that's probably about
volume
seven or eight how many volumes are
there over twenty
so what does that wasn't season three
announced already i think so yeah i'm
sure i'm sure netflix wants to keep that
that coming and yeah i am very happy
with that and it gets different and it
gets more and more interesting after
that because i'm hoping we finally get a
[ __ ] anime that finishes in anime
form we never [ __ ] get it anymore
we're getting it like the latest one i
can think of that we're getting is is
attack on titan and that's only like one
of the most successful animators
that's the whole [ __ ] world watching
it for them to be like
maybe we could just finish this one
it's like it's like the streets are like
start new anime yeah finish old one and
then
like this
no
stop finish this one finish because it's
just like if an anime gets over three
seasons like because even even if we get
a season two that's just like that's
just like getting the table scraps right
you're like oh my god i can't believe
i've got a season two
[Music]
like playing mashup
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off is this doing well
you cannot tell me this this deserves a
second season no game no life doesn't
[ __ ] right yeah
but uh yeah so b stars so you think it's
like up there's one in classic now
because i i i think so the ending wasn't
exactly like amazing amazing like it was
just a solid ending if we get the full
anime adaptation of the manga in the way
that it's going right now it would be
considered a masterpiece
man i personally would see it as like uh
easy like nine out of ten at least i
mean i mean i i can i can see that like
if if the anime keeps up the quality of
the story because i love season one but
it felt like season one just felt like
it's kind of a setup season it's like
the the ending of b stars is very much
like the ending of part six where it's
like the people who love it love it but
the people who didn't like it were like
you know
yeah i mean it's like a lot of people
say that it's like kind of an
anti-climactic ending but i thought it
was kind of fitting to how the entire
story went because like
the final part of beast does there's
like this big fight that happens
obviously of course but and and then
from that big fight it kind of suddenly
winds down into just like regular stuff
okay and like to a lot of people that
was seen as anticipation i like that
though i like a little breathing time to
say goodbye yeah right i mean i like to
all right guys just kind of read a few
more chapters with you guys before you
guys [ __ ] off forever yeah
what gets me sometimes is i know like
the there's always the hype around the
last chapter right because the last
chapter you saying goodbye to everything
and you know this is this is where this
is and people like try to put a
conclusion in the last chapter whereas
some of like my favorite manga is when
that last chapter is just the climax is
over it's done it's purely just an
epilogue and i feel like epilogues are
so [ __ ] underrated in so many anime
and manga because most of the time it's
just like you get to the final episode
right and half of this episode is the
climax so you've got like 10 minutes to
say goodbye to all these characters
give me a follow-up yeah give me a
friend i hate the epilogues that are
like
there's like like seven minutes left of
the episode it's like yeah are they
gonna are they gonna stick the landing
and then you know that it's a rushed
epilogue when they start talking and the
ending song plays yeah no no no and it's
not even it's not even an epilogue it's
just like a slideshow of just like here
here are the characters now
oh here they go
um and then we have ichigo 100 which
again for me is like another i wouldn't
even it's weird what's this about i've
i've i've
explained this okay so ego 100 is just
this really just super simple
rom-com okay essentially like you know
how shonen jump every time right they
they replace harem wrong comms right
like once one harry roncon ends another
one takes its place okay
issue 100
100 was the one that well first of all
like it was like right at its prime when
i started reading shawn and jump so
again big nostalgia fact i'm gonna
completely admit that but second of all
to me it is like the one manga series
where there was no one clear winner like
right up until the end it was like all
the girls are so liked through and
through like people think quintessential
quintuplets is like the ultimate like
any one of these girls could win type of
thing it's like yeah no no it's not each
girl 100 is because you start off with
liking one girl
as you do with any harem wrong comrade
of course but but but if you are saying
i don't know how the [ __ ] cost the music
you did it but she did it in a way where
by the end of it any one of them could
win
but you don't know who like right up
until the end and it's just so simple
but so well done and again like i like i
really like college numbers giza style
because again very different it almost
super 90s oh yeah i mean because it is
very well
they all look like the chobits robots
oh yeah they do they yeah they look like
the same era it looks like the exact
same character design as well they look
like they're like all robots
and it's weird
to fall in love with you boo beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep right because
it's like to me it's not even the best
rom-com manga oh okay it might be i
think so is this a harem rom-com how
wrong well we all know that joey loves a
good one i like that
i love a good harem roll don't get me
wrong in my opinion the best rom-com
manga ever written his eyes which is
also from shonen john which came before
this one so like this one basically
replaced eyes i've heard if i got an
anime adaptation didn't that in like
early 2000s yeah i was like it was like
a very [ __ ] adaptation
it wasn't it wasn't very it was
forgettable that's all i know
but um yeah it's it's done by the same
guy who made a zit man
oh okay okay i'm like all of those he's
done a lot of manga um but yeah i don't
know again this was one of those shows
that i think this show is the reason why
i love harem wrong
okay so do you read did you watch the
anime adaptation of this at all it's an
anime yeah there is there's an anime
adaptation it's not good oh
basically everyone every like
basically most of the shows on here have
like very mediocre anime adaptations
like aside from these stories
but that's true
yeah probably you yeah
but uh yeah um and then we have uzumaki
of course honestly anything from junjito
could have been in here again he's
probably the reason why i love horror i
mean i i do think uzumaki is like kind
of like in terms of like a long form i
think he is his magnum opus i think so
some of my favorite works of ginger yuto
isn't using but just his one shots
actually yeah i feel like uzumaki is his
like only long-form work that i think is
like the best yeah and again like that's
that's why i i feel like i could have
put anything in there like i also
[ __ ] loved tomie which was his first
one that he made which is also
brilliantly horrifying like if you love
like your kind of bondi body dysmorphia
macabre horror type of thing i do really
want to read gingy too at some point
yeah yeah it's part of the mo it's again
it's a trip it's on the infinite list of
i need to get right now it's just like
with jinji ito you don't even need to
like be that invested in it because i
like i think the best entry point for
june to you so it's just to read some of
his one shots because like i feel like
like one there's only like a few genres
that really work well with one shots and
horror is some of them because all he
has to do is like he hits you with this
like really weird [ __ ] idea and then
he just ends
yeah it's like he he definitely like has
taken a lot of inspiration from like
classic asian horror in the sense that
the stories don't necessarily make sense
but at the end of it you're somehow
still invested and still terrified yeah
it's purely that he purely just assaults
you yeah with all of these senses of
just super disturbing [ __ ]
and then kind of just like
that's the end
how do you feel
how do you feel
how do you feel
why are you here
yeah so obviously i i think it's no
secret that i love you
yeah um and then i guess we'll just talk
about the center one
there's a reason why i put it in the
center because i still think to this day
it's one of the greatest manga series
ever made it's the one manga series that
i know like i'm i'm building myself up
yeah it's like it's like i've watched
the last season of bojack horseman it's
not because i don't want to yeah i just
i'm just kind of not in the mindset
where i want to be depressed i mean you
know with your three by three right you
were talking about like the one that you
enjoyed the most and the one you think
is the best is different yeah yeah this
is definitely that the one that you
think i did not enjoy
at all yeah like you don't enjoy it but
you just can't stop yeah yeah but it's
one of those i i
know this even though i've never read it
it's one of those
series or stories from why i understand
that it's just it hits you and it sticks
with you and it's like you you read it
once and it's just a part of you i just
got like [ __ ] to do you know like i'm
gonna be sad for like a while yeah right
yeah i gotta deal with it i remember i i
binged this manga for the first time and
i i finished reading it at like four am
yeah and i just kind of the moment i
finished it i just kind of closed it and
just sat on my couch i know exactly
let's say after every bojack episode
yeah and then they're like then they're
automatically playing the next one like
no no
give me some time
but i think i think the one thing that i
really like about oyster pumpkin is the
fact that it almost like it almost goes
beyond manga like what iniosano did an
oyster punch is so like we were talking
about metaphors before right with uh you
know i shall 21 stuff like that yeah the
metaphors in oyasumi poonpin are insane
because
literally like what kind of mangaka has
the balls to turn their main character
into a metaphor i think it's genius i
think it's absolutely genuine so to
explain oyster punch for those who don't
know
this is the main character his name is
pumping
um he's a bird character but and every
other character in the manga is a human
yeah but all the human characters see
poonpoon as a human it's okay so it's
like how he sees himself
it's how he sees himself but it's also
how you as the reader see him
as well so like throughout the manga as
he's got so basically it's this manga
where it follows this life of
growing up so he starts off as a kid and
he turns into a teenager
i don't like the sound of this yeah i
don't like it
[Music]
i know it's gonna be [ __ ] and it kind
of very slowly yet steadily it goes
through every inch of his life
there's a lot of things that happen to
him and around him that are very [ __ ]
yeah that's how it looks yeah yeah so
like you know it starts off with him as
a kid he meets this girl
you know learns what falling in love is
right learns the the the joys and the
heartbreak of puberty and then i feel
you man and then that drags on with him
and then he has family problems he has
problems with his friends he has
problems with basically just a broken
life you know it's a broken life
and what's so brilliant about oyster
punton is that as obviously you know
like when he like gets older he's he
gets bigger and taller but still the
bird
but then there are certain points in the
manga where his look completely changes
so there's one part in the manga where
he just turns into a floating pyramid
for about two chapters oh okay and it's
not really explained why
it happens but as you're reading
metaphor context yeah it represents
something in here okay and it's very and
it's very literal in that sense
how long is it how many chapters i have
seven volumes i own it's all of
i've owned all of them for years it's
been city it's 12 volumes i think okay
well hundred and twenty kilometers like
[ __ ] okay so i own seven of them
well no i believe at least the
translated volume yeah the western
volumes are a lot thicker yeah yeah
they're a lot thicker so i have iron
there's 13 volumes in japan is it but
it's like 120 something chapters oh so
you could probably read it in one day
you could easily written i mean i read
it in one day like it's it's been
sitting on my shelf i think for years
it's just been staring me and i'm like i
stare at it and i'm just like today the
day it's today it's tuesday did i read
it no just the thought about reading i'm
unhappy
basically yeah
my very first experience with hearing
about yasmine pinpoon was actually like
when i first started dating sydney and
uh
so i um this was when i back when i
didn't know sydney too well and she gets
really really invested in stories right
and stories she's one of you know one of
those people that you know gets truly
gets invested and involved into a piece
of fiction
um so i'm just here sitting and sitting
in my room sitting in my office doing
like youtube videos or whatever um and
then i hear sydney just like bawling i
mean this is like this is like i'd never
seen her cry harder than this yeah like
she was like like beyond ugly crying you
know it was like i came in and like mike
was wrong
my god just sang because like i've only
like this is the kind of reaction you
see when someone's family member just
died you know and um i'm just like i
take a few deep breaths i'm like okay i
know i know we're gonna have to deal
with something serious something's
really [ __ ] up and i'm just like
honey are you okay what happened she
just went i just finished a manga
and i i know dead ass just went
what
what
and she's like
let's go like you ask me
but yeah like i
i i mean like i didn't like ugly solve
at the end of poon poon but yeah there
were definitely moments throughout pune
that
i kind of just opened my eyes wide and i
was like holy [ __ ] like there were many
times where i actually said to myself
out loud i was like no
no
you're not like this no it's not like
this
and it's like and again it's like it's
the way that he can somehow
fit this [ __ ] bird character into a
super realistic context of like very
realistic setting with very realistic
characters yeah and give this bird this
the most human life possible is so
insane to me and the fact that he can
just do it seamlessly like you know
obviously at first if you're going into
this blind yeah first couple of pages
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
what what the [ __ ] is this bird yeah
but you kind of like learn to grow with
it and again like you know it's it's one
of those things where like a lot of
people say like oh he turned it into a
bird so that you yourself can put
yourself into pinpoint situations
yeah so that if you're not fixated on
one particular type of person you know
when concerning looks and stuff like
that like you can just imagine this is
any human
and it's just yeah and again it's like
ini osano literally just took all these
like
rudimentary concepts about manga and
just went through out the window and
just went i'm just gonna draw what i
think is cool
and it's like there's lots of like weird
[ __ ] in it as well but like
i mean i've been trying to write a video
about this manga for so long but
literally every time i reread it first
of all i get destroyed for about a week
so i try not to do it but second of all
there's just so many subtle things in it
that i keep picking up on that i didn't
before that just completely makes me
change the way i view this manga and
it's just yeah it's insane
so like again probably the manga i
enjoyed the least yeah yeah but
definitely one of the best yeah in my
mind
that's what i assumed it was going to be
which is just like i'm not reading this
manga to enjoy it i'm reading this manga
because i know it's probably going to be
one of the most
like powerful pieces of media i've ever
consumed yeah and that's that's like my
assumption going into it and the final
chapter made me cry like [ __ ] crazy i
was like [ __ ] man
it's brutal but yeah um i don't know
what else i can talk about yeah i
realized that you know even though i've
read a lot of manga you know what at the
end of the day
shonen jumps just kind of the king to be
honest i mean it's it's kind of the king
for i mean it's how
yeah yeah i mean shonen jump just has a
formula and i don't know what that
formula is but they just keep it works
they just keep pumping out bangers not
just bangers like everything they pump
out just seems to be like a global
sensation and even if it's not it's
going to have some kind of cult
following behind it it's just kind of
the ones that i remember the most for
some reason like like [ __ ] now like i
remember when the big three ended or
like you know naruto not the big three
but the ear of the big three were naruto
bleach in one piece one piece is
obviously still going on but everyone's
just like what's going to replace it how
can anything replace naruto and bleach
that's those were like global sensations
then my hero came out and was just like
hold my hold my beard and then demon
slayer came out and i was just like hold
my sword
and then like [ __ ] now jiu jitsu
kaisen and now like chainsaw man's
coming out which is going to be a
massive [ __ ] in here like
where do they miss when that like
are they [ __ ] aimbotting like what's
their secret like what the [ __ ] is going
on
no legit and it's like you know again
it's like you know you you kind of get
in that period of your your manga
reading life where you're just like you
know what
maybe maybe it's time to graduate from
the show now yeah you know it's it's
like it's kind of formulaic i want to
try something new so you go out read
some of the the more obscure scene in
manga or like the shoujo or the you know
the jose manga or you know some like
weird gore or edgy type of [ __ ] and it's
like there's lots of good ones don't get
me wrong but at the end of the day
you're always going to go back to sean
and jump yeah i don't know what it is
i remember i i said i said that opinion
on twitter and i got a lot of [ __ ] for
it
and i'm like
there's a reason why it's still the
greatest they hated him because he told
the truth exactly
[Music]
so uh yeah i don't know is it normie
i don't know it's berserk normie i feel
like berserk is legendary i just i just
seeing the fact okay i'm more than half
of these are shown in john i will say
this now i've got berserk on my three by
three as well and i was just like can i
justify not putting berserk on my three
by three and i just i just went through
these like this like mental gymnastic of
just like
is there any manga that i could like
feasibly put over berserk no no like
there's the it's it's the goat for a
reason right he's one of a kind talk
about it at the end maybe yeah
yeah but i i honestly like good no no
trash tastes here you have a very solid
list uh obviously there's some that i
haven't seen
um
well-rounded though
to anyone who's never read any of these
obviously berserk please go read that
yeah uh b star is [ __ ] fantastic and
if you can handle it please read awesome
improvement right it will change your
life i do want to read most of these
yeah yeah
i mean slam dunk as well as one of the
greatest i want to slam
because i [ __ ] dude actual 21 took me a
long time it's got a lot of slam dunk's
got 30 volumes
it's gonna take you some time i mean i
i'd say there's a lot of these though
but the payoff is all right
if you like your sports mama you kind of
need to if you like sports
yeah
this is the quintessential sports manga
and that is joey's taste you can judge i
mean we've we've had two very solid
three by threes now
i'm kind of worried about mine now i'm
like oh [ __ ] actually put up gunslinger
all right all right let's take a break
and then okay guns like click manga
version this episode is sponsored by
manscaped do you have a problem
maintaining your bush if so manscaped is
here to help you thank god for manscape
because i sure do have a problem with my
bush luckily or unfortunately joey's
bush is doing better than australia
right now and thus he needs a lawnmower
4.0 which is manscaped brand new
lawnmower join the 2 million men
worldwide who trust manscape tm by going
to manscape.com trash taste for 20 off
and free shipping it's hot as hell right
now and you know what doesn't need to be
moist
your pee these nuts
and thanks to manscaped i don't have to
worry about these nuts
ready for an out of world experience
fellas well look no further than the
performance package 4.0
damn that's a lot of performance in a
package well inside this package you'll
find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all of your stuff in
god damn and you can get this in the us
and canada and the uk and across europe
australia south africa and singapore
anywhere in the world you need your
balls trimmed manscape's got you the
weed whacker is also waterproof and uses
a 9 000 rpm motor powered by a 360
degree rotary dual blade system so if
you want to protect these nuts then go
to
manscape.com trash taste for 20 off your
order and free shipping that's 20 off
plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com trash taste if you also
want to become a sigma male use
manscaped these nuts back to the episode
if you guys read poompin i'll read honda
all right
go on pull up my three balls pull up the
three by three let's see some of these
shouldn't be surprises at all
okay okay
okay well let's let's go through the
odds
okay so so before before we get into it
there are some that i feel like i would
put in there if there wasn't already
like an amazing anime adaptation of it
right i really want to put vinland saga
on there for some for for example but
i'm just like well i've also really
really enjoyed the anime um so you want
to go through them okay so from
uh going down from uh oh great teacher
onizuka kingdom
the breaker
20th century boys domestic girlfriend
love hina
berserk
beck and siren siren really yeah i was
not expecting cyrus what is is breaker
is it the korean one that's the man
that's the man yeah yeah to me like
break it out i'll start off a breaker
because that's the only one on there
that is actually not actually a manga
but a manual um i feel like breaker is
that one it's it takes it's basically
everything i wanted from a shown in
anime that you could not get from shonen
jump because it's it takes the kind of
the shonen
shonen jump like battle battle manga
formula and adds martial arts to it and
it's it's so rare to see something uh to
see a manga that just does martial arts
well and i've kind of realized if if i'm
looking for martial arts because you
know if if you watch the uh
film three by threes you'd know that i'm
a huge [ __ ] fan of kung fu movies and
stuff like that right and it's just so
hard to find that same vibe in the
martial arts i mean you know god of high
school as well yeah yeah so you got like
god of high school
they don't really care about kung fu in
japan
yeah exactly in a sense yeah almost but
like veritas is like the perfect balance
between martial arts and superpowers
because people are like still very human
in here and you know you can still take
someone out with a gun but they have
enough power that they're kind of also
superhuman as well right so it's it's
kind of balanced in that way and like
it's like it's it's got like a very you
know it's got a very standard story it's
it's about
this guy who has zero martial arts
powers and zero key as you know that's
which is the power system here um and he
meets he just meets this guy who you
know he's beating up some street thugs
and turns out he's just like a [ __ ]
you know martial arts master or whatever
right and so to help teach this guy or
to help this guy basically
like
protect himself and not be bullied and
all that um he gives him like this
medicine which you know is technically
he he gave it to him by accident
and uh ends up this guy is just like
obviously a secret genius in martial
arts and
kind of like takes on the entire martial
arts as well enhancing drugs of course
always say yes of course
what if we could use 100 percent
but like it's it's like it's cooler but
like in terms of like formula yeah it's
a very very standard formula but one
okay like the art is [ __ ] fantastic
the cover looks amazing yeah it's so
it's like so much more detailed than you
see in a lot of just standard shonen
jump manga right and what blows my mind
is that this was like a weekly release
but the art quality is that of like a
monthly release manga you know what i
mean like one punch man for example is a
monthly release right so you you can see
why you know it took the time to be to
make to make it a monthly manga this was
released weekly and it's not as good as
one punch man in terms of high quality
but it's like way better than pretty
much most standard shonen jump weekly
manga damn and it's like the action
choreography and the action art is
[ __ ] insane and it's just
it's just like pure fun it's just pure
if you know what you're getting this guy
is like a weak link okay but the amount
of times that he [ __ ] he [ __ ] does
something badass unexpectedly is just
like it's just insane and it keeps like
the stakes keep rising and rising and
what i love as well is they really build
up i really love the board building of
just like the secret organization that's
of like martial artists who like kind of
rule the world you know it's it's like
in real life yeah yeah like in real life
it's got like it's got like the same
kind of like vibe as john the john wick
world if you know what i mean i'm down
for that i love john obviously obviously
the main protagonist isn't john wick
he's it's someone who grows into someone
who's going to be that skilled in that
world
but it's kind of got that same vibe in
world building and it's just i [ __ ]
love it and not enough people talk about
the breaker i've definitely heard of the
title because it's just one of those
shows you hear when
some someone says oh you know [ __ ]
amazing manual right like us what was
the other solo leveling right
that like i hear a lot of and then i
really need to read i mean solo leveling
i feel is
it's it's it's good but it's i don't
know why so loving works so well it's
it's basically just an easter car in
disguise but for some reason um it's it
feels i think it's mostly carried by the
arts right the arts just [ __ ] amazing
mama art is like next level i don't know
how they do it so consider literally
every manual i've read has just been
like oh my god yeah i i really don't
know how they do it so [ __ ]
consistently yeah it's insane um
and then yeah what what else do we want
to talk kingdom uh i haven't read
kingdom i've been i'd rather bring it
i've read the first five volumes of
kingdom because i read it long right uh
it's 60 volumes it's it's like
okay okay it's still going
it's still good okay okay okay i
remember because i remember when i was
like trying to get new manga to read i
was just like
[ __ ] you now this has 500 chapters i'm
just like oh for [ __ ] sake right um
and then i read the first 100 chapters
in like two days and i'm like thank
[ __ ] god this has 500 chapters it was
it was like one of those manga when i'm
just like i'm so glad that there is just
like an infinite number of chapters
it's not that i dread it's that i dread
that i literally can't do anything else
like i can't watch anything i can't read
anything else because i love that i'm
like that's that's the feeling i'm
constantly looking for because i love
the feeling of just being so absorbed
into this manga or anime or something
that i literally can't get on with my
life unless i
unless i'm finishing this thing because
like that that to me is like pure
enjoyment right and kingdom gave me that
for like a good like month i i only i
only had time just a month
i lost the month of my life i think and
it was like the best month ever i only
read like the first five volumes of it
because i was like at a manga cafe just
like chilling waiting for a friend or
whatever and i had to leave i was like
no i'm not leaving yeah i need i need to
continue reading this is [ __ ] insane
yeah so so like so like to give the to
give a brief like sell yeah
um so it's like when china was like
fragmented into different different
kingdoms
you see
you see what they did there three
kingdoms yeah um no it was uh i think
this one has seven kingdoms right and so
it's the story of it's just it's just an
epic basically it's it's the very
definition of an epic where it's just
the story of uh so one one like there
was there's one farm boy shin who's the
main character and by complete chance he
meets um he meets one of the future
kings of the kingdom that he's living in
right
and throughout the entire history of
china no one's been able to unite all of
the kingdoms no one's been able to like
take over everything and just unite
everyone and so it's very simple it's
just the basic story of the king growing
up to be a king and uniting everyone and
it's the farmer who the farm boy who
grows up literally as a peasant and um
it's his story of becoming the greatest
general uh of china it's basically if
you took the golden age arc of berserk
and just made it in epic yeah
that sounds good yeah
which is awesome because golden asia was
[ __ ] awesome i love the golden age
yeah like imagine the golden age arc but
um
the biggest to me the biggest selling
point of kingdom is the battles so
this man's drawing over here
he can't contain his love for kingdom he
went down he's choking up thinking about
it
yeah i just want to talk about kingdom
okay
so i have never seen any
other piece of media
depict warfare in as much detail as i
have kingdom right
because there's only like there's it's
been 500 chapters and one single battle
can easily take up like 50 to 100
chapters
yeah it's like lord of the rings
yeah i mean it's battle for helms deep
here yeah yeah yeah yeah literally like
imagine every battle imagine if that was
just every battle right but it's [ __ ]
ins it's actually [ __ ] insane go for
it are we close to finishing the story
no we're about halfway oh [ __ ]
that puts me off because i i don't want
to get into something where i'm going to
be like 50 years old and i'm like hey
son uh my favorite manga is finishing
kingdom literally every one piece fan
but like but it's it's it's one of those
manga where it's it's such a simple kind
of it's it well it's it's simple and
it's not right because obviously there's
a lot of there's a lot of like politics
involved there's a lot of like
intricacies into how they basically take
try to take over their kingdom because
there's i really can't condense it down
into like whenever i'm getting it's an
epic yeah it is an epic
but like it's because it's broken up
into like different arcs you can just
read one arc and you just you can just
like stop it it's kind of
you can take a breather like i literally
binged one arc then binged another arc
and then binge another because i'm just
like i just want to see what happens at
the end of this battle and
it's it depicts what like i said it
depicts warfare in a better way than
i've ever seen in any other market
because like you know
you know how they like try to write
smart characters in a lot of fiction
whereas you to to write a smart
character you have to make the other
character dumb right so there's been so
many like there's been so many like
warfare kind of scenes where it's just
like they they introduce this like
really smart general or something and
it's because he sees a strategy that the
other general doesn't see and it's like
to the reader it's the most obvious
[ __ ] strategy of all time we're gonna
go around the back yeah holy [ __ ]
they'll never know if they flank them to
the right yeah exactly and and with
kingdom the reason it takes like about
like 50 to 100 chapters per battle is
because it's they're pretty 5d chess
they are like it's it's it's so
incredible to see so many styles of
generals battling against each other
because it's it is literally like
watching two gm's play against each
other and no it i i'm absolutely serious
because like you're you're turning the
page and you're like both both sides are
making moves both sides are like taking
pieces they're taking rooks they're
taking bishops it is kind of like
watching a chess game except it's
because it's a battle it's not just it's
not just all about strategy sometimes
you have people who [ __ ] flip the
board and there's and then there's
nothing you can do about that just
because they're too powerful and there
are some people who knows that this guy
is someone who is going to flip the
board and he takes that into account and
so
the winner of the battle isn't the
person
is isn't the person who's like
necessarily dumber it's just the person
who maybe thinks that extra half step
ahead and you really don't know until
you turn like the final few pages of an
arc how it's going to turn out the
author must have like [ __ ] binge read
like the art of war like
honestly because like honestly i've only
heard like the most insane i'd like to
let this be like the other like those
reviews yeah yeah
five stars yeah like my work
without spoil without spawning it's like
some of the best moments of this manga
like i think with this
this uh this manga has an arc which is
one of my favorite arcs of like all of
manga and that's that's because it's
like it's an arc without spawning the
exact plot points it's an arc where you
have like [ __ ] five six generals all
of them have like are making [ __ ]
playing 5d chess with each other making
moves against each other and you're just
like holy [ __ ] i can't even keep up with
the amount of strategies going on and
the different pieces like that that are
being pushed around it's absolutely
[ __ ] insane it's so big brain that i
really cannot explain
again ever since i read those five
volumes of kingdom i've been this close
to just been saying [ __ ] and just
buying the rest of the volume is it
published weekly
okay that's good that's good it's
published but there's no way they're
gonna get to five dollars i've just
given up the hope on manga where they're
like okay now we're publishing monthly
all right and i'm never gonna read it
because it's never going to finish yeah
if you want to see like the brain
expands me more of just like of just
reading something that is just like
super smart without making making it
like seem pretentious or something yeah
and the artist
i think someone asked i don't know who
was when george are mine this question
is like if you're not smart how do you
write smart characters
if you're not smart yourself how do you
write a smart camera yeah yeah like
legit i just i still i remember they
answered something but even me i was
thinking about i i don't know how you
would how would you because you wouldn't
know what smart is because yeah yeah so
yeah it's like i think this is
this one because this is what smart
people are like yeah it's like how do
you ask your smartphone how do you write
a smart character who's like 300 iq when
you're not 300 iq yeah
what i would
what i would uh guess is that
they are uh the author of this must have
just studied so many like history
historic battles because some of like
the taxes and strategies that can they
come up with this it's just like it's
300 iq versus 302 iq and it's just like
it's just like that extra two iq that
gives them the edge in battle it's porn
that matters yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
it's uh it's it's such a good absolutely
if you want something that is just an
incredible epic read kingdom okay uh
great teacher only zuka classic is a
classic and i've heard all about this
yeah i watched it
it's weird i've never read the manga for
this i've only watched the anime i've
heard the anime is amazing yeah the
anime is amazing but i've heard the
manga is even better the the i think the
anime is i mean it's it's good because
the manga is [ __ ] amazing right
that's that's that's that's the only
reason the animation because like he's
so goddamn good you can't mess up this
it's like cause like because like you
okay have you seen the anime i've seen
the enemy when you think it came out
uh
what the anime yeah
it was like late 80s right
it came out in the year 2000.
i'm not joking are you serious i am
still a trap question i felt the track
set up when you asked that
well it feels like late 80s it feels
like late like early 90s it feels like
late alien late 80s early 90s anime
adaptations yeah it came out in the
2000s it came out after cowboy bebop
but because
but because like because the anime are
the same
crisis on the gto today
so i mean i think i've talked about gta
briefly before but to uh to give to give
a brief synopsis of gto it's about it's
about this teacher who is delinquent oh
he great oh he great oh he's a great
team he's no no no no he's not a great
teacher yet because he's just he's he's
he's uh so his name is onizuka and he's
delinquent who finds himself in a
teaching job right and let me guess let
me guess he's just
he's he's not a good teacher in the
start but he he learns to love the kids
and he wants to help the kids so he
becomes a good teacher no actually he he
wants to be the greatest teacher in all
of japan hence the name great teacher
but uh what he he's given like a very
problematic class right
and uh yeah he's he's not like the
greatest teacher academically and that's
part of like that's like part of the
point of this manga is that he doesn't
teach academic lessons he teaches life
lessons and i know
i know i know i reach these kids he's
not he ain't book smart he's streets
but like how you wear a bag kids make
you sort it correctly yeah but like if
but like it's
it's a manga that i think really
affected me when i read this as like a
teenager because
you know it it sounds it it is like a
completely cheesy kind of um setup right
because you know it's just oh this it's
a teacher who reforms a problematic
classroom and teaches them life lessons
it makes them appreciate life and stuff
and yeah that's that's exactly it's it's
a it's probably
the best feel-good manga i've ever read
japan loves those kinds of manga they're
like yeah there's another manga like
that called rookies i don't know if you
know that one i don't it's like if you
took gto but you made them play baseball
and but it's like it's the exact same
like feel good vibe you have the
delinquent teacher who like teaches a
bunch of delinquents to like join a
baseball team and stuff like that yeah
exact same feel as gto is like just as
good it's just it's just really it's
it's also a comedy one and i i do like
the comedy but like what i really love
is that you know it it it's not it
doesn't teach you so much cheesy life
lessons right it's so much just just
teaches you
that
you especially growing up in asian
culture it tries to teach you that you
know grades and
like this the school system isn't
what defines you as a person and i feel
like a lot of people might need to like
hear some of the things that this manga
especially
especially in japan and especially in
asian culture and kind of the cherry on
top is just how [ __ ] goofy and at the
same time badass onizuka is um i [ __ ]
seeing the antics he seeing the antics
they put him through is just like
everything is such a treat like what my
one of my favorite one of my favorite uh
scenes in the manga which never got
adapted to the anime was like he was
trying to
he was trying to teach just like this
like leader of like this uh gang to like
try try to attend school and take it
[ __ ] seriously and all that [ __ ]
and so
um
this guy this this student leads him to
like this underground like fight ring or
something i can't remember the exact
setup but he's just like look
if i arm wrestle a hundred of you and
win
then you gotta come to school and it's
just like this is this is so this is so
[ __ ] stupid right because it's just
like how are you going to [ __ ] arrest
arm wrestle 100 people and then he he
beats one person he beats two persons he
he starts he starts taking on three at a
time and like he's three out of ten yeah
yeah he starts taking on three times
it's the shonen mark okay yeah and it's
just like it's the way the way that it
just kind of builds up and like
escalates is like
hilarious and badass at the same time
and it's it's something where it's not
100 serious but when it hits it [ __ ]
hits and some like it's a manga that can
really
i wouldn't say change a person but it
if if you're looking for something that
affects you in the opposite way of pun
pun where it's just like wow it uses
comedy to teach you not depression yeah
it still teaches you like very important
life lessons but it it you feel
wholesome i feel like i don't want that
like genre of manga is so like beloved
and known and quite you know more common
especially to a japanese audience i feel
it's slept on in the west
probably like there are so many like
good like feel good comedy centered like
lesson type of manga that is out there
and they're all [ __ ] great yeah
because i feel like to do this type of
manga or to do this type of story it's
so hard to just not be cheesy yeah you
know like and i feel like gto is that
one manga when i'm just like
like you you see this done in any other
way and it would just be cheesy but the
way that they do in this just
it almost doesn't take itself seriously
yeah exactly yeah exactly
um so yeah onizuka is like i think one
of my favorite characters in manga
for that reason
uh what do you want to go on next can we
talk about siren
okay why is siren what is siren what the
[ __ ] is that
it's shown i'm surprised you've heard of
siren i [ __ ] love cyrus you love
sauron oh my [ __ ] god that's why
that's why i was like why is this here
because
it's one of those like it's one of those
who's explaining the place underground
shonen jump manga that like it didn't
have very long run time did it um it had
like a good 100 chapters did it it got
cancelled that's right yeah it did yeah
i will tell you the plot okay so um
there's going to be like a slight
spoiler but i feel like it's within the
first four chapters and i feel like it's
it's it's a big twist that i feel um is
what got me hooked into this manga right
so
um so it's that's the main i can't i
can't actually remember the character
names because it's been so long since
i've read it but it's this main
character and
uh he
i don't think there's anything too
special about him at the beginning he
runs a service where he solves he solves
problems right that's got nothing to do
with what happens right and so he sees
this girl
um it looks like she she uh she looks
like she's going through some issues or
something so she he tries to help her
and in that process
he
he follows her and then he gets
transported with her to just this
new place he doesn't know where he is
right
um
yeah he basically gets isekai right goes
to another world yeah yeah
he goes to another world
he goes to another world see a theme
here yeah no he goes to another world
with this girl right
um and then they're in just in just in
this like barren wasteland and then they
get transported with a bunch of people
and it's kind of like the gans kind of
theme where where it's it's not let it's
not as brutal because it's like shonen
jump gans so it's not it's not got like
massive gore but like people just start
dying left right and center right and
for some reason she has like a special
psychic power that she uses to survive
so he kind of follows her right and so
in like fighting through this kind of
death game kind of barren wasteland kind
of thing
he
he like tries to figure out where the
[ __ ] he is how he got there and what the
[ __ ] going on right and then it's like
the big twist at the end of episode four
is that he goes on top of this like
like uh building that's just been like
laying like it's it's like uh what's the
word i'm looking for like abandoned or
not not abandoned but it's just like
it's what what's the word where it's
just like like it's been years since
this building's been overgrown
dilapidated dilapidated yeah it's this
the lab station building right and he
and he goes on it and then he sees mount
fuji right
and it's just he realizes
that
for some reason he's in japan he's in a
city that is in complete ruins and the
apocalypse has happened and so he
doesn't know how he got there or where
he is that's right or
should i say it
okay i'm gonna say okay
or when he is
but i mean i guessed when you were said
that he's in japan yeah yeah time thing
yeah i said it was dilapidated
signal the passage of time yeah yeah so
so that i i guess i guess that that
spoils it but
but yeah i mean so what i love about
this is that
it's a shonen jump action manga that had
that has has a mystery core because the
core of this is him going back to his
own world or his own time and kind of
figuring out what the [ __ ] happened
how did it happen
and in that process like i'm that's
that's all i'm gonna say because in the
process there's so many twists and turns
that come from that and him trying to
figure out what's going on
um and it was just nice to see
like a shonen jump that has action in it
but also has this really mystery aspect
that keeps you coming back and just
keeps you like reading the next page
just to figure out what happens because
i feel like there's there's been shown a
jump with a mystery aspect for example
uh what's the one where they eat kids
again i promise no one promised
nevertheless like been like promised
neverland and it's been like obviously
i've never heard perhaps an airline b
described as what's the one where they
eat kids i mean what am i wrong i don't
know why i got it right away am i wrong
am i wrong i
is what it is like shenanigans it's not
what it mean it
the one about the kids trying to escape
it's the one where the kids get eaten
like i i like i i like the fact that it
had a mystery aspect and also a battle
shonen aspect and i feel like it was so
underground because nobody [ __ ] read
it i think the problem with siren is
that it kind of came out at a time where
shonen jump was just absolutely stacked
where like everything else in china
because this was like
mid-2000s shown in right so this was not
only in the midst of the big three but
also like the lesser known shonen jump
stuff that was not the big three was
still very very popular so why do they
get cancelled then um just because it
wasn't popular enough yeah i'm just like
i feel like i feel like another thing is
that unfortunately the art style just
looks so generic because this came off
the bleach it doesn't look
like the main character looks like
ichigo yeah yeah it kind of looks so
generic but it has so many original
ideas like i really like
without spoiling what the main
character's power is so like anyone who
goes to this world gets a special power
of their own right and i like as an
engineer
he has like a really unique power where
i'm not going to spoil exactly what he
is but he can't control this power like
he can't
consciously control this power so what
he does
to kind of figure out a way different
ways to use his power is he makes
subroutines
for for this power so it's basically
like he makes programming loops for this
power to like follow a set algorithm to
do exactly what he wants
and i'm just like that's such a unique
idea like slowly remembering this monkey
man
can type 2 000 words per minute
but yeah like i mean i could i could put
i could have put like hunter hunter or
other shonen jump manga on here it's
nice to see some variation but yeah like
i said every every shonen jump manga i
can think of putting on here has an
anime adaptation so that's that's the
only reason why i put siren on here
because it's my it is my favorite shonen
jump manga that does not have an anime
yeah because it got cancelled because it
wasn't popular yeah isn't it the other
one i would put on there is uh did you
ever read m0 i did not read it okay
that's another one that was like kind of
it came out around the same time as
siren where shoney jump was just stacked
never got an anime adaptation but it's
so good what's that about
m0 is about it's this basically it's
this kid who enters this magic school
but he himself has zero magic abilities
yeah so this is literally like think of
like [ __ ] might here academia right
but instead of quirks it's magic power
and you have like certain levels of
magic and the higher your magic level is
the more powerful like a magic card you
get that can like activate magic skills
and the main character again he has zero
magic so he gets an m0 card oh okay and
it's just him basically just trying to
basically survive and graduate yeah
magic school but like the art style is
so unique and it's so it's such a dope
solid story but again it's never got an
adam adaptation and like hardly anyone
read it because again
jump no it didn't get cancelled it had a
proper ending it got like 12 volumes or
something oh and i had a proper ending
it just no one read it because during
that time shonen jump was so stacked
right all these other insane shows it's
stacked now as well stack now but like
mid 2000's showing and jump was like so
you can you can recommend it even though
it doesn't have an ending like is it oh
no it has an ending it's just very
rushed uh but like everything by the way
they're like wrap it up come on i mean
the same as well yeah but like i i feel
like i can still recommend it because
the mystery aspect got solved and it got
solved in a decent amount of time what
didn't get what was like a bit
unsatisfying was just each character's
resolution because it got wrapped up so
quickly but the mystery aspect which was
the reason i was so addicted to whis and
reading that gets wrapped up just fine
and that's why i can still recommend it
so uh what's love hino about
wait have you not read osha no i don't
know i don't know really i don't know
anything about love you know wow love
hina okay
this
i'm i'ma say right now this is nostalgia
i mean look i'll come on skins
explain yourself what is it about it's
nothing you haven't heard before um it's
it's a manga where a guy loves hina oh
for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it interesting i don't know that
that's naru oh yes that's naru and okay
so a guy
um a guy moves into this to
uh her his grandma's onsen right because
uh his grandma owns a nonsense uh and uh
it turns out it's also a girl's
dormitory and uh
and uh okay it's a [ __ ] haram anime
okay it's it's uh sorry it's a harry
manga okay okay okay and uh how can i
say this it's uh
classic it's it's just a solid harrow
manga and i there's there's nothing i
can do to convince you to watch it i i i
i'm not gonna try and convince you to
read it okay i'm not i'm not i'm not
here this isn't for you connor this is
for me this is for me
this is this is god's ichigo 100
honestly this was the very first manga i
have ever read oh really yeah yeah yeah
out of everything right because i
remember watching it was the first anime
i ever watched because before that i had
this like first anime no i'm sorry sorry
it's the first
animation this anime the first anime i
watched where
before that i had this massive complex
against manga right because i was like i
know because like i discriminated
against manga honestly honestly because
i'm like how can you get into black and
white drawings i'm sorry i'm sorry this
is disgusting this is for peasants
western western comics go through the
trouble of coloring in where's the
movement where's the color where's the
color i'm just like how am i supposed to
get into this and like love hina was the
first anime i watched where i'm just
like
i want to see what happens
i'll fight through the black and white i
want to see what happens enough that
i'll [ __ ] read the monk she looks
cute but she looks like a like a pokemon
reject
um she's uh i think every character in
the 90s yeah yeah yeah it's true because
i think they all had like the same kind
of thing so out of ten
i mean i i've
just give me give me a [ __ ] score
gone what is it how [ __ ]
that that stutter was a five that's it i
i think loving it to this day is like a
solid six or seven
i think it's just a fun six or seven
it's a [ __ ] if if you like harry
manga
which you don't so okay if you like
harry monk i still think lafina is such
is a very very sword it still stands up
to us why did you love harem anime i
have manga so much like what about the
harem speaks to you god oh that's like
girls eh
i want all the girls okay
i'll i'll break it down okay because
this is gonna be a really weird analogy
um if i'm like if there's a harem manga
that i'm invested in it's not it's not
specifically about oh there's a bunch of
girls what i equate reading a harry
manga to it's kind of like watching us
watching a sports match right because
like no you're gonna [ __ ] say that
yeah yeah because okay because pick your
team when you root for them you pick
your team and you get emotionally
invested right
you pick your best girl and you [ __ ]
root for them and you stick through it
through thick and thin yeah and then
even if they don't win
they've won in your heart yeah if even
if they don't win but if they do win
it's like it's it's such an emotion
yes
yes
yes you literally become a [ __ ]
sports fan i bet god's never as happy as
when his [ __ ] harem
part of the best part of harrens right
is being he's watching it with the
community because like half the fun is
seeing your girl win but also half the
fun is [ __ ] on the fans of the
losing girl as well that's like that's
like equally as [ __ ] that's what i loved
about it 100 because i read it with a
bunch of my japanese friends who were
all just as invested and they all had
their own winners and when i when my
girl won i was like [ __ ] you
i told you joey had the biggest dick
that week i did
i felt good
okay so like i mean it's i still think
it's a solid harem i think one of the
biggest differences to a lot of harems i
met is that i do like the character
development of the main guy he starts
off as obviously a [ __ ] loser with no
personality but as the series goes on he
actually develops why don't we ever get
chad's
where's the space for growth if they're
already achieved they become more modest
maybe they love modesty no one wants to
see
[Music]
is uh 20th century to say domestic
violence
i was about to like give you the
background yeah while we're on [ __ ]
let's keep talking about domestic
girlfriend if we talk about love here
okay he's not going to stop talking
we've seen it on your channel yeah we
can go we've seen your videos we can
literally go and get the fountain of
like non-existent youth from you on this
this thing where you just never age and
you talk about this for ten years i can
i can continually talk about it i don't
wanna give me a five minute you get five
minutes gone sell this to me because i
watched i watched three episodes and i
immediately dropped domestic girlfriend
[ __ ] awoke something in me man
like
you this this this
single show basically dictated my hentai
taste from like so there's me before
domestic girlfriend and there's me after
domestic
so
if i'm correct is it there there's a guy
and there's a teacher yeah and there's a
sector okay okay so that's correct okay
so
let me break it down for you okay so
there's this guy who has who's in love
with his teacher right and
one day he just randomly goes up to a
meet-up and uh he meets another girl at
a karaoke uh what's it called in a car
like uh
what's what's what's what's the event
where
i make sure thank you sydney you know
she goes to a mixer and he meets this
girl and this girl for some reason wants
to lose her virginity because she just
at the age where she's just like [ __ ] it
i got nothing better to do doesn't the
anime literally open with them like yeah
after the anime literally opens the with
them just off
right and so he sleeps with this girl
and then he's who he's just met and then
they say goodbye
um and then he goes home and then he
finds out that his dad's getting
remarried and then he meets the
family that he's getting like his dad's
getting married to and it turns out that
the mother of or his future
mother-in-law
uh or his future stepmother
uh she has two daughters
one is the girl he slept with and the
other is the teacher he's in love with
and that is the premise of this
girlfriend
literally this is this is incest and
this is just like this is like what if
we made all pawn categories into one
this is what it sounds like basically
this is like basically combine every
port where are the laundry machines okay
four of them in this house
okay so like i will fully admit that the
the concept i mean yeah this is this is
a hentai block okay this is this is your
this is this is your kisses this
like when we did the anime three by
three people were like why why is the
domestic girlfriend anime not on there
it's because i actually read the manga i
think it's a good [ __ ] manga and i
would defend it till the day i [ __ ]
died would you say it's a masterpiece i
would say i mean
it's a masterpiece in my heart okay okay
no because like i understand because
like what happens is like this
masterpiece is short for masturbating
yes but like okay what i love about this
manga is that it takes the most like
it's the situation is a complete car
wreck and it just turns to a car wreck
to a train wreck to a [ __ ] nuclear
holocaust like
the like the layers of how
complicated the situation get just let's
just get stacked on top of each other
but
what what offsets this is that it's
actually a really well written manga
it's like a a lot of following you're
being very oxymoronic right now okay
okay okay because a lot of thought was
really put into the characters so the
characters actually seem really
realistic and you can kind of like
empathize with them right
what's
what you can't relate to is the [ __ ]
situation that they're in so you put
really
you put like you put actual like
realistic characters or well written
characters into this really [ __ ]
trashy wacky situation and it's such
it's like a juxtaposition
of just you're actually invested in
these characters but also the stuff
that's happening is so wild that you
just want to keep reading just to see
what happens next it's like a soap opera
but the characters are actually really
like you're really really invested in
these characters
i i just couldn't get to that point with
the anime honestly
what's more of a battle this or kingdom
what's more of an epic battle
it's two different battles isn't it
which is the bigger battleground oh oh
oh
i don't know which one's more five head
man one of them is like you're
physically getting hurt because the
other is like chipping away your brain
yeah okay because because like the anime
is a really okay what the anime did is
that it just took all the trashy moments
in the manga without any of the
character moments and just put them and
just speed ran it so it made a bit of a
bad pawner huh they made it bad yeah but
he made a bad porno okay
it's uh i mean what what porno doesn't
have character development well well how
can i implement most of them a good one
we don't need it
and uh yeah i i will i will keep talking
about the dimensions i'm sure if you
want to talk about it just ask him in
public ask him anywhere
watch the 17 videos he made on it i
realized i realized that uh i've made
like a manga three by three uh hentai
three by three i'd say a dojin three by
three this is all and uh an anime three
by three and all of them have incest in
there i just i just want to say where is
this saying i just want to say for the
record i i do not like incest you are
very lucky you're an only child
that's all i'm saying otherwise the
internet would have destroyed yeah
if i put this many in settings in mind i
won't be like yo carl's got three
brothers oh i've got a sister and i've
been [ __ ] look all i'm saying is at
least i don't like stepmom porn because
everyone has a mother what like everyone
everyone everyone has a mother what's
your excuse what's your excuse connor
for mother's no mother knows breasts
let's get into that
all right let's let's talk about 20th
century boys okay because that is a that
is actually a good manga okay this is
my favorite manga it's brilliant i've
never read this i've been wanting to
read this i've actually got it
downloaded ready to read everything but
i can i can give you the manga volumes
instead oh you have them with you yeah
that's in english yeah in english that's
that's the model
well the cover looks badass yeah so it's
[ __ ] amazing so 20th century boys is
my favorite manga of all time and i've i
only read this just before moving to
japan and it's it's it's kind of like
the oh yes me punishment where i knew i
would love this for ages and i held off
reading it until i had just the right
amount of time and the right mindset and
that just so happens when i had the few
week break before i moved to japan and i
was like okay i am now ready to
experience i'm now ready for emotion and
it lived up to everything and more i
like i knew it was like a magnum opus of
a piece of work yeah and i still like
it's it's amazing but also it like every
every lesson and every message you try
to say like spoke to me personally as
well so it was kind of like a mixture of
personally this was my kind of story and
also it's an amazing story this is this
was the manga that made me go wow
he's a [ __ ] genius can you give me a
very quick rundown of the show sure
okay
so oh oh it's pretty convoluted applause
it's it's a very give me the most
bare-bones explanation okay so i'll try
to sell you this as quickly as possible
so
um so imagine like when you're growing
up as a kid right you play hero and
villains right
and so
like you you play a hero and someone
plays the hero and someone plays the
villain and normally a super villain
they try to take over the world right
it's a cartoony plot they take of the
world and the hero stops them now what
if you could make this very childish
plot believable
that is basically what 20th century boys
is right sounds cool it's someone who
basically
tries to take over the world and naoki
naoki hiroshima went how can we actually
make this actually seem realistic and
terrifying and terrifying as well that's
that's like the bare bones basic premise
of this what i love about this is that
it's kind of like a mystery so it
doesn't open up with that that premise
what it opens up with is this guy who's
just a normal guy who stumbles upon
a conspiracy right
and so
of course you stumble upon a conspiracy
and you see how deep this how deep this
conspiracy goes
yeah yeah exactly exactly
and it the way the story unravels is
that
like you are given pieces just to how
how deep this conspiracy
this conspiracy goes and how far it runs
and the more chapters you read normally
like you see a mystery and like you can
you're able to like kind of get a feel
for like how big this mystery is right
what i find [ __ ] amazing about 20th
century boys is that i was like 5 to 10
volumes in or something like that and it
felt like i was staring into an abyss in
terms of this mystery like this this
this feeling where you just don't know
how deep this rabbit hole goes like you
you're just like there's no way this can
go deeper then something gets revealed
and you're like
where does this end
how the [ __ ] how far this does this go
and like the way that and that's what i
find i find that incredible there's no
but no other mystery that's just giving
me this feeling of just like it was kind
of like almost existential dread because
i didn't know how far this sank or how
deep this went
um and it's probably like it's my
favorite manga of all time i think it's
my favorite mystery of all time
i'm so so amazing at writing these just
mysteries where it's just like you don't
know where it's going and also
i don't know about you but urasanaki i
feel is a genius at writing
some of the most perfect antagonists
yeah in manga i mean he also did monster
yeah right yeah okay you should have
said that yeah oh yeah yeah it's the
same guy
same guy
but like monster is like way more
character driven and i think it's like
much more small scale this one is like a
[ __ ] massive scale it sucks so much
to read now
and like this is this is never going to
get an anime adaptation because
i mean compared to monster this this
would be like hundreds of episodes maybe
because that's just that's just how like
monster was like 70 something episodes
yeah this would easily be like 150 200
episodes yeah yeah make it happen honey
got over 148 true yeah and yeah i i feel
like it's the greatest manga i've ever
read and it's definitely up there yeah
yeah yeah
is there anything more than that can you
give it a higher praise than that that's
that it's it's mine i guess i have to
read it [ __ ] me yeah it's brilliant it's
my uh it's it's it's i i like i can't
even pick a favorite anime of all time
but the fact that i can pick a favorite
manga of all time it's telling that's
telling ladies and gentlemen we got him
we got him and it's not domestic
girlfriend
surprisingly he walked in the middle
don't [ __ ] for that
i i didn't put anything significant in
my middle one i just clicked
i mean i should have should have it was
the oromo square that's why i put it in
the middle yeah
and you have well two more i guess one
more we'll talk about berserk after uh
beck
the manga for background i've only
watched the anime
you've only watched the anime joey joey
i'm showing my character
i actually love that
i mean dude i [ __ ] love the anime and
again
same thing everyone's saying the manga
is even better the manga is even yeah
before you get your dicks out and start
comparing them what with you the plot of
back i know nothing i mean it's it's
like uh it's it's a musical right [ __ ]
off it's not a musical it is
just music yeah he just plays music he
just joins a band and tries to get big
yeah so come on come on [ __ ] off i'm not
even joking i'm not sick i'm not joking
that's really the part of what's good
about it then
it's just this it's just the journey
it's it's completely character-driven
you looked at me dead in the eyes and
you said it's the journey well it's just
like
[Music]
it's uh what i love about beck i mean
it's a very simple story in that sense
it's a completely character-driven story
where
it's about a boy who joins a band and
they're very underground they're trying
to make it big um and it's literally
just their journey of making it big
right and you know i mean you've seen
movies and [ __ ] you know
star is born huh a star is born yeah and
obviously there's i mean this is sabrina
miley cyrus hannah montana
the best of both worlds sorry think
about that but just like better
how
[Music]
it's very heavily reliant on the
characters but like the way the
characters are written and just the how
they like play off each other and like
all of the i mean a it's very realistic
which is already like a big plus for me
especially with like a character-driven
story like that but also it's just like
yeah i don't know it's just a really
good journey do you think i'd enjoy it
uh do you like rock music i enjoy rock
music i mean it's it's if if you are
like to me
mark zuckerberg answering that
do you like human things yes i like
human things
i kind of realized i asked the person i
enjoyed
do you like rock music i i do enjoy rock
music i felt like the pressure was on
for some reason sorry go ahead
yeah i mean it's what i love about beck
is that it's just all
it just captures
the you know the love for rock and you
know good old you know old classic rock
and roll and just like how rockets
evolve through time so so do they
mention like all of like like did they
mention the fact like they play like a
cover of the beatles and [ __ ] yeah yeah
how does
is it
you know because i i just thought about
a second i'm like oh wait surely you'd
want to listen to the music right yeah
so that's why i watched the anime yeah
that's what i think yeah
i thought that as well right because i
was just like [ __ ] i kind of really want
to know what happens but i don't know if
i can get invested in a um in a [ __ ]
manga about music where
i don't i don't know if you know
anything about manga but uh you can't
really hear anything that's going on in
the market don't have audio yeah and
then i realized and then i realized the
[ __ ] i i kind of realized a super
life hack uh when reading beck right
because what because you know i i also
watch the anime that's what got me into
reading the manga
um and i realized that when they're
playing
in their concerts and it's like you can
literally just play whatever song you
[ __ ] love and you feel the [ __ ]
emotion [ __ ] brain
know i gotta go through expansion
playlist brain expansion i mean like you
can do it if you if you kind of like
want if you want to like really get
invested and really like put yourself
into this rock concert but what what's
amazing about the manga is that it
somehow captures the energy of a concert
so [ __ ] well and like if you've ever
been to a gig and if you've ever if
you've ever like seen sorry sorry thanks
thank you connor thank you now i'm so
bored
i sneeze when i'm born
conor when he listens to someone talking
about music
reaction
music yeah so someone like read musical
sheets near me
no if you've ever been to a gig and
especially like a rock concert there's a
certain like energy to seeing your
favorite bands live and i don't know how
the manga the manga which is a medium
where you can't hear anything it
captures the energy so well
that you can play the music of whatever
your favorite band is and you're just
like holy [ __ ] i'm feeling hyped and the
reason this is saying the feelings yeah
yeah yeah exactly and the the music is
just like
kind of like complimentary to that as
well
um and like if you like if you like the
anime joey then you're gonna [ __ ]
love the manga because the manga takes
the best parts of like the best scenes
of what happens in the anime and there
are there are scenes in the manga that
are like five times as hype as anything
that happens in grateful sounds i know
what i'm buying next
yeah yeah and like it's it's hard to
sell back uh if you haven't seen the
anime because if if you haven't seen the
anime i think that's the best way to get
into the manga because it's like i said
it's a musical manga um and it might be
a hard sell if you don't know if if you
don't know what you're getting into but
if you like
but if you like rock if you feel like
good old rock and roll i still remember
that scene in beck that made me be like
hell yeah it was like the the scene
where he does the cover of i got a
feeling by the way yeah yeah that scene
is like the most [ __ ] like
hell yes moment it is so good i don't
know what you're talking about it's such
a great it's such a good thing it's just
so steeped in rock culture yeah that's
uh if if you're if you like that
there's a lot there's a lot of people in
japan who just love [ __ ] rock and
roll yeah yeah yeah people was like you
know you see a british like oh sex
pistols yeah
yeah yeah that's that's a british
foreign
honestly like they make so many
references to like real life bands
something i also love as well yeah like
like they say like oh with this person's
inspired by hendrix or sex pistols
there's another manga that does that um
exactly right
that was the joke i was gonna go for
and uh of course the uh only square
that's been taken up by all three of our
three by threes
um rightfully
i think last time we spoke about it i
don't think i'd finished it on the
podcast had i no
yeah caught up but i mean hey you could
tell it was nearly about nearly done
yeah
it kind of had like its own somewhat
conclusion
around that point i mean
when i was reading it and i saw the
dreaded i saw how many chapters i had
left yeah a little sinking feeling was
coming from my heart but
you know i i still i i'm i'm very thanks
i felt like he was so close to the end
like we were there like he was he was
literally prepping yeah he was prep
i still think he had a lot
i don't know because he he you know you
know how before a big raid you know you
get some new armor you get some new
stuff right that's what was going on it
was definitely a prominent fight coming
we were gonna and it was gearing up that
it was like all right we're getting a
big boy fight yeah yeah yeah we might
have been like 10 years away but
it was coming it was coming it was on a
plane
it was like oh she's coming i'm like
yeah i mean
do we need to explain the plot of
berserk do we
i mean it's just i guess we should a
little bit right if you haven't read
this there's probably people watching
this who have not read berserk yes i
mean i was one of those people would you
like to explain the plot um
there was a boy who was orphaned uh he
was thrown to the wayside in a pile of
horrible fluids on the ground and uh
there was a woman who was like no we
must pick this up and the mercenary band
that was traveling with this one was
like no let him let him die and die but
then somehow the woman convinces the man
to let her pick the baby up and raise
this child who is going to be guts our
main character and as you can tell this
upbringing is not the best and hor many
more horrible things happen to this
child through his upbringing but
so many gross things but the band of
mercenaries also train him to be a
warrior
and then you know because he said so
many bad things happen to him during
during his childhood he becomes kind of
the the lone gamer warrior that we all
think is the coolest thing ever uh but
you know the black swords yeah the black
swordsman right the guy who can carry
the big ass swords
the one who can just beat everyone alone
right and and you know
slowly realize that that's a bit of an
empty life and uh wants to make friends
and then uh bad things happen very bad
things happen um
and bad things continue to happen and
it's about
getting over those bad things and trying
to learn to accept people and love again
i suppose in certain ways um it poses
itself as this like
big bad guy with a sword fights monsters
and bad dudes and tries to survive the
wall but at the end of it you realize oh
it's not about that no it's about his
journey yeah it's about it's always
always about that it's it's always it's
always about this it's about it's about
him
it's it's literally just like a monger
about his life yeah and the cherry on
top is just god tierra
the art is just insane like it's it's
just no one can draw like nero yeah um
and like if you haven't read it you know
i was i
i had not read it for a very long time
yeah i knew it was good but i just
didn't do it you didn't know how good it
was i didn't know how good it was i mean
i've watched the anime and i thought it
was pretty good that's pretty yeah it's
good this thing is pretty alright
okay wait the 2016 anime
or the 90s
okay i was about to [ __ ] say that's
what i was going to say right now
we did not do that here we go
and yeah i read it and i'm saying like
if you're if you're sleeping on it or
you've been putting it off like now is
the time like you know what it's still
fresh in everyone's hearts you know yes
it's
pay tribute to the king read it it's
amazing it will you will not regret it
like it has
i dare i say a little something for
everybody
i mean there's a reason why whatever you
want out of a manga i guarantee you'll
get something out of this there's a
reason why
it's been goaded forever yeah it's not
it is not just like over hyped at all it
is it is just right it is it is not over
hyped
i thought of every possible reason i
could to not put this on my three by
three because it's just like it's just
the one that i think we all know that we
were all gonna everyone it's just like
the manga that goes on everyone's three
by three and i'm just like can i be that
person yes you're deserving i have had
many manga uh that i one of many most
that i've had one two one or two
chapters that i have like you know what
let's just kind of speed run this part
let's get through it first yeah i've
never ever ever felt like that during
berserk even though i'd i'd seen the
first arc yeah i still was like [ __ ]
this is good taking my time exactly like
what i find incredible is that you know
people will look at berserk or people
who have never read berserk they look at
it and they see oh musty man with big
sword go bro you know that's that's
that's that's kind of like what it looks
like on the cover but like what everyone
who's read berserk and the moments that
stand out in berserk and the parts that
people remember are always like the
quiet instruments yeah it's the
beautiful moments and that's and that's
because there's the juxtaposition
between like the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happens and the bloody and gory and
amazing action that is in the manga like
it's juxtaposed with some of like
the most beautiful moments you can find
in fiction just the scene of god
standing in the field of flowers yeah
just that that whole like mini arc if
you will yeah it's like one of my
favorite moments really yeah i was just
like oh [ __ ] they just took like they
were like hold up yeah
yeah because i feel like i feel like the
story of berserk speaks to just a call
that so many people can relate to like
hey
you know to get [ __ ] real for a
second like if you've ever felt lost in
life or you don't know what your purpose
is or you don't know
if it's worth it if you don't know if
it's worth it or why you're [ __ ] here
like if you're just ever having a bad
day
like that's exactly what guts goes
through in berserk you may look like a
big muscly man but he like the journey
that he goes through is exactly the same
realization that a lot of us
have gone through in our lives you know
under that hunk of muscle there is a
heart you can't you can't chop your way
through every problem yeah yeah yeah
that's what you know he tries and he
realizes no he can't see as much as we'd
all love to be the overpowered mc like
at the end of the day that that's not
going to help you solve every problem
yeah yeah that's what uh you know just
it shows you i guess in some ways not to
get too lost in the things that are
right in front of you right which is a
lot about what berserk is about yeah i i
think i think the scene that sold me on
berserk if like if i can get to like
small spoilers of the golden age arc
um it's it's like the scene after he
beats like the hundred men because like
you you think in warfare you [ __ ] one
man takes on a hundred men that's
[ __ ] badass in any other anime that
would like that's framed as like holy
[ __ ] this is an incredible feat which it
is yeah and like i like i remember like
it was just gutz's reaction it was just
realizing it doesn't [ __ ] mean
anything yeah like also the aftermath of
everyone coming in the forest yeah
seeing him just murdered a hundred yeah
yeah yeah just like disgusted they're
like what the [ __ ] how is this man alive
yeah yeah
[ __ ] but yeah that is it's it's
afterwards that he just realizes i'm i'm
doing this for no reason i'm literally
just killing 100 men and it just means
nothing to me
yeah like even right away like even
though um i you know i think i said this
in uh the last episode uh the last time
we spoke about berserk i do think that i
would have preferred um the first part
which they because they they have like a
time skip i would have preferred they've
just put that in the right time right
because i feel like it kind of oh and
just start from like golden age yeah
yeah i think it would have been perfect
to start from there um even though i'm
sure people disagree with me um because
i feel like you get so many
really cool experiences if you didn't
know what was going to happen yeah um
and also just getting to see
his childhood from the start yeah would
tell you all about the how [ __ ] up
this thing's going to be yeah i guess i
guess they needed a hook right to you i
think so i think that's why but like you
know i wonder
if it was done again
you know would it would it be ordered
differently looking back
i don't know um that's obviously just
pure speculation yeah and i'm sure
people would uh completely disagree with
me and that's fine that's opinions right
that's what yeah
i think especially is especially what
happened recently berserk's really
changed my perspective on how i view
media as well because i'm just like
before i'm just like something that's
not finished can't be a masterpiece and
then i think about it and i'm just like
berserk is a pure example of something
that has done more than [ __ ] enough
to be a master yeah like an unfinished
masterpiece is still a masterpiece you
know and i i feel like i that's really
changed my perspective on other shows
which may maybe not ended it may never
end and i'm just like well i think it's
still done enough to be called like a
masterpiece yeah and i think berserk has
really showed me that as well i agree
yeah real berserk read berserk please
and listen to guts's theory even if
you're not into dark fantasy i think
it's still i'm not into darth vader i
still think it's it can be very much
enjoyed
i mean i guess there's nothing else to
say really there's nothing else that was
uh i hope you've had some new
recommendations yeah i mean you know
what god not bad i mean let's let's
let's take into consideration this
middle one
get that [ __ ] out of here i love that
other than that good choice good job
anyone who's read domestic girlfriend
knows that this [ __ ] slaps but uh yeah
let us know uh you're three by three
he's on the subreddit because
it's just that good it's it's like you
know putting uh salt in my favorite like
condiments it's like of course i mean it
needs to go on everything like would you
i'm not come on don't don't boo me i'm
right so three by three of essential
things i put water water
uh yeah please send us your three by
threes on the subreddit uh go follow us
on twitter and joe you can go and do the
rest of this okay well hey let's talk
about our patrons first of all oh yeah
let's uh let's bring them up on the
screen right now
i'm sure they have good taste but this
guy right here has a great taste in mind
i'm sure grant gaylord has great taste
i love that yeah he has the best
girlfriend in his manga
i know he does but hey if you like to
support the show then make sure to go to
our patreon patreon.com also follow us
on twitter uh send us your memes on the
subreddit or your three by threes on the
subreddit and if you hate our faces
listen to us on spotify cheers gamers
yeah i i i honestly like there weren't
too many surprises this episode i know
we went from trash today we weren't
trash taste we were great tastings yeah
gentlemen taste yeah
refined taste refined taste
episode with minimal arguing exactly
i just feel like manga there's so much
less variation in taste because everyone
knows what like if it's like good things
if there's a good manga like everyone
can kind of agree it's a good manga no
no one no one reads like 200 chapters of
something that they are not enjoying you
know
so yeah that's been this episode of good
taste i guess we'll see you guys soon
all right bye bye
[Music]
you